des finances pour 2023 et la parole est
à Monsieur Arnaud Bazin rapporteur
spécial de la commission des finances
pour 5 minutes et je vais demander à
chacun de rejoindre sa place et de faire
un peu de silence pour notre collègue
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le projet
de loi de finances pour 2023 propose
d'ouvrir 30 milliards d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement et en crédit
de paiement au titre de cette mission
cela représente une hausse conséquente
de plus de 2 milliards d'euros par
rapport à la loi de finance initiale
pour 2022 soit environ 8%. cette hausse
s'explique principalement par
l'indexation à l'inflation du montant
des prestations sociales financées par
la Mission la location aux adultes
handicapés la prime d'activité auquel il
faut déjà désormais ajouter le RSA dans
les départements où sont financement a
été recentralisé à elle seule ces
prestations représentent plus des trois
quarts des crédits de la mission
ainsi le coût de la prime d'activité en
2023 dépassera le seuil symbolique de 10
milliards d'euros ce qui est bien sûr le
signe de la dynamique du marché du
travail mais aussi de la faiblesse des
salaires les dépenses d'allocation
adulte handicapés quant à elle
dépasserait les 12 milliards d'euros la
mission regroupe une grande variété
d'actions qui reflète la diversité de la
politique d'action sociale pour le temps
qui met un parti je souhaite ma pesantir
sur l'enjeu de l'aide alimentaire cette
politique ne représente qu'une faible
part des crédits de la mission avec
117,2 millions inscrits au PLF 2023 mais
le sujet est crucial dans la période
actuelle en 2020 année marquée par la
crise sanitaire on estimait que
5,6 millions de personnes ont fait appel
à l'aide alimentaire
le problème s'intensifie depuis
l'inflation est très forte sur les
produits alimentaires et fragilisent
considérablement nos concitoyens les
plus modestes la situation est également
préoccupante pour les associations
d'aide alimentaire celles-ci sont en
quelque sorte victimes d'un effet ciseau
entre un afflux de demande qui ne flippe
faiblit pas et des moyens de plus en
plus contraints en premier lieu
l'envoler des prix d'électricité alourdi
fortement leur charge de fonctionnement
tandis que la hausse des prix des
carburants affectent les bénévoles se
rendant sur les sites de distribution
surtout les tensions mondiales sur les
marchés agroalimentaires sont à
l'origine de nombreux lots infructueux
dans les marchés passés pour leur compte
par France agrimaire pour l'achat de
denrées je me permets une brève ainsi
sur ce sujet de ces achats en principe
éligibles à un remboursement par l'Union
européenne dans le cadre du FSE plus en
pratique les contrôles effectués en la
matière sont si pointilleux qu'une
partie significative des produits
achetés finalement déclarés inéligibles
remboursement la simplification des
procédures est absolument indispensable
et cela fait maintenant plusieurs années
près de 5 je crois que nous lançons
l'alerte sur ce sujet avec Eric Bocquet
dans ce contexte il est indispensable de
prendre des mesures de soutien efficace
à cet égard nous nous félicitons certes
que ce projet de loi de finance prévoit
de renforcer de 60 millions d'euros les
crédits alimentaires nous avons
cependant des divergences quant à la
méthode retenue puisque cette enveloppe
est destinée à la création d'un fond
pour les nouvelles solidarités
alimentaires dédiées à financer des
projets de transformation des structures
en liant lutte contre la précarité
alimentaire et soutient aux filières
agricoles durables il constitue en
quelque sorte une issue au débat qui a
eu lieu suite à la Convention citoyenne
pour le climat autour de l'introduction
d'un chèque alimentaire proposition que
nous ne soutenons pas car elle tourne le
dos au modèle français associatif fondé
sur le couplage aide alimentaire et
accompagnement social
nous considérons qu'il conviendrait de
se montrer davantage pragmatique et
d'utiliser cette enveloppe nouvelle pour
soutenir directement le fonctionnement
des structures voire pour compenser de
possible l'eau infructueux dans l'esprit
de l'enveloppe de 40 millions d'euros
qui avait pu être adopté cette année en
LFR sur une initiative de notre
commission des finances
je suis loin de partager les
orientations du gouvernement en matière
de politique de cohésion et de
solidarité ce sont les revenus du
travail qui permettent de sortir les
personnes de la pauvreté et non d'échec
ponctuels distribués par l'état de temps
à autre même si le gouvernement a pris
le fâcheuse habitude ces dernières
années mon collègue Eric Bocquet
reviendra sur ce point néanmoins en
responsabilité et afin d'assurer le
financement nécessaire de la prime
d'activité et de la location adulte
handicapés je vous propose d'adopter les
crédits de cette mission
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Eric Bocquet rapporteur spécial
de la commission des finances pour 5
minutes aussi
les ministres mes chers collègues nous
sommes intéressés à la dynamique
importante des crédits de la mission
depuis 2019 si nous tirons le bilan de
la période récente que constatons-nous
chaque année depuis 2019 des enveloppes
supplémentaires ont été ouvertes en
urgence sur la mission d'abord en
réaction au mouvement des gilets jaunes
avec une majoration de la prime
d'activité qui représente un coup
pérenne pour l'État d'environ 4,4
milliards d'euros par an ensuite pendant
la crise sanitaire avec le versement au
printemps puis à l'automne 2020 et de
deux aides exceptionnelles de solidarité
en faveur des bénéficiaires des minima
sociaux et des aides au logement d'un
montant de 150 euros avec une majoration
de 100 euros par enfant à charge et
représentant un coup de près de 2
milliards d'euros
plus récemment et les faire 22 2022 une
aide exceptionnelle de rentrer de 1,2
milliards d'euros a ensuite été votée
nous avons dans cette commission
assurément des visions très divergentes
en matière de politique économique et
budgétaire je pense cependant que nous
pourrons tous nous accorder sur un point
cette politique du chèque entre
guillemets n'est pas une politique
sociale elle permet uniquement au plus
pauvre de nos concitoyens de passer le
mois sans leur donner la moindre
perspective et ne résout rien aux
problèmes de fond le budget de la
mission ne peut pas lui seul absorber
les chocs sociaux qui trouvent leur
racine dans nos fragilités structurelles
je pense en particulier à la question
récurrente de la faiblesse des salaires
il y a certes des points à quelques
points positifs dans ce budget je pense
par exemple à la déconjugualisation de
l'AAH prévu à compter du 1er octobre
2023 cette mesure était très attendue on
ne peut que regretter le temps perdu en
la matière avant que cette réforme ne
soit enfin arrachée au gouvernement à la
faveur de la campagne présidentielle
cette mesure vient conclure un
quinquennat contrasté en matière d'AAH
puisque la revalulation la
revalorisation pardon de son montant à
taux plein de près de 80 euros a été
contrebalancé par de discrètes mesures
d'économie une revalorisation importante
de la hache a eu lieu en 2018 puis en
2019 relevant le montant mensuel de la
location de près de 90 euros pour le
porter un peu plus de 900 euros en 2021
sur le quinquennat cela représente un
effort global de 3 milliards d'euros
même si elle est maintenue en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté mais en parallèle de
discrets coudrabo ont été décidées pour
modérer l'évolution de la dépense
réforme du plafond de ressources des
personnes en couple suppression du
complément de ressources sous indexation
de la revalorisation légale annuelle etc
au total ces mesures d'économie viennent
capter plus du tiers de la dynamique
créée par la revalorisation de la hache
soit environ un milliard d'euros sur les
5 ans
pour de nombreux bénéficiaires cette
revalorisation a donc été largement
théorique en tout état de cause son
montant resterait nettement sous le
seuil de pauvreté peut également être
cité la poursuite de l'augmentation des
crédits dédiés à la politique de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
les rapporteurs spéciaux relèvent la
poursuite de l'augmentation des crédits
en 2023 les crédits demandés s'élèvent
en effet à 54,5 millions d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement soit une
augmentation de 15% par rapport à la loi
de finance initiale 2022 le volume de
l'enveloppe reste cependant bien modeste
lui égard à l'ampleur des enjeux et aux
difficultés rencontrées par les
associations de défense des droits des
femmes qui sont également frappés comme
beaucoup d'autres de plein fouet par
l'inflation à titre personnel je m'en a
été remis à la sagesse de la commission
des finances sur l'adoption des crédits
la Commission comme vous l'indiquez à
l'instant mon collègue Arnaud basin a
décidé de vous proposer leur adoption
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Sol rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des affaires sociales
pour 3 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et les
ministres messieurs les rapporteurs
spéciaux mes chers collègues les crédits
de paiement de la mission solidarité
insertion et qualité des chances s'élève
à 29,9 milliards d'euros pour 2023 en
hausse de 8,3% par rapport à 2022 sous
l'effet notamment de la revalorisation
des prestations sociales et de la
décongivalisation de la location aux
adultes handicapés c'était toutefois
vrai la semaine dernière mais un
amendement du Gouvernement déposez
vendredi
pourraient ramener cette hausse à 7%.
nous espérons obtenir cet après-midi
mesdames les ministres de plus amples
explications sur la diminution de 568
millions d'euros des crédits dédiés à la
prime d'activité et aux revenus de
solidarité active
le budget de la mission pour 2023 à
Paris comme un budget de transition où
l'on entrevoit des chantiers du
gouvernement en matière de lutte contre
la pauvreté l'insertion et l'emploi
la stratégie nationale de prévention et
de lutte contre la pauvreté arrive en
fin de cycle des crédits consacrés à
cette action diminue de
327,6 millions à 252 millions d'euros en
2022 et 2023 les actuels conventions
état département arrivant à échéance en
cours d'anglais un nouveau pacte des
solidarités prendraient la suite avec
des axes nouveaux concernant la lutte
contre la grande marginalité et la
transition écologique et solidaire le
gouvernement m'a lancé plusieurs
expérimentations
relatives au RSA qui ont vocation à
converger vers le projet
France travaille dans des conditions qui
ne se dessine pas encore avec évidence
nous suivrons également avec attention
le projet de solidarité à la source qui
pourrait permettre de fiabiliser le
versement des prestations sociales
s'agissant de la prime d'activité en
particulier une amélioration du
versement à bon droit de la prestation
est indispensable selon la Cour des
comptes un neuro de prime d'activité sur
5 soit 2 milliards d'euros au total se
réverser à tort à titre définitif par
ailleurs la Commission apportée
attention à la traduction budgétaire des
avancées de la loi du 7 février dernier
sur la protection des enfants s'agissant
des mineurs non accompagnés alors que
les flux d'entrée semblent repartir à la
hausse la contribution de l'État aux
dépenses des départements continue à
baisser de 93 millions d'euros en 2022 à
90 millions 2023
sur tous les crédits inscrits en loi de
finances on s'en rapport avec les
dépenses réelles de l'État en 2022 sur
les 28 millions d'euros qui ont été
ouverts en compensation des dépenses
supplémentaires à la charge de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance seul 3 millions
d'euros seront répartis entre les 11
départements ayant accueilli plus de MNA
au 31 décembre 2021 par rapport au 31
décembre 2020 le mode de calcul de cette
contribution doit être révisée car il
est en coupé décalage avec la réalité du
terrain sous ses réserves de la
commission des affaires sociales a donné
un avis favorable crédit de l'émission
je vous remercie je ne peux pas donner
des secondes et des minutes
supplémentaires dans dans ce cadre là je
suis désolé si vous voulez revenir
samedi ou dimanche vous savez que le
temps est très contraint alors dans la
suite de notre discussion je vous
rappelle que le temps de parole attribue
à chaque groupe pour chaque unité de
discussion comprend le temps
d'intervention générale et celui de
l'explication de vote par le
gouvernement dispose au taux au total de
10 minutes pour intervenir et la parole
est à Monsieur Philippe mouillé pour le
groupe les républicains pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente madame le ministre
monsieur le Maire rapporteur mes chers
collègues s'il y a un domaine où
l'effort de la nation ne doit pas
faiblir c'est bien celui de la
solidarité et cela de ton plus vrai en
cette période difficile
les crédits de la mission augmentent de
8% mais dans le contexte d'une inflation
qui s'établit actuellement à
6,2%. il faut souligner également que la
hausse correspond principalement à la
déconjugalisation de la hache à la
revalorisation des prestations sociales
et à l'augmentation de la prime
d'activité avec la crise sanitaire
économique et sociale puis la soudaine
baisse du pouvoir d'achat la hausse du
coût de l'énergie chacun a pu mesurer
combien de filets de protection sociale
sont précieux qu'il s'agisse d'un
système de soins du chômage partiel de
l'aide alimentaire ou de la continuité
des droits sociaux
malheureusement malgré tout cela environ
9,3 millions de personnes vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté en France
le gouvernement a multiplié les mesures
d'être ponctuelles pour faire face aux
urgences et d'exceptionnelles de
solidarité prime de rentrée majoration
du chèque énergie prime d'inflation
cependant ces aides ne remplacent pas
une réforme structurelle de lutte contre
la pauvreté comme l'ont signé nous
rapporteur cette politique de chèque est
aujourd'hui certains de nos concitoyens
mais quand sera-t-il demain quelle
perspective leur ouvre ton notre modèle
social montre ici ses limites et le
budget de l'État n'est pas inépuisable
concernant les réformes envisagées je
voudrais former quelques observations et
interrogations le gouvernement a lancé
plusieurs expérimentations relatives au
RSA dans le sillage de trois
départements d'outre-mer qui sont deux
heures déjà engagées dans cette voie la
loi de finances pour 2022 expérimente la
recentrer des espions du RSA la
Seine-Saint-Denis et les
Pyrénées-Orientales rejoint le
dispositif qui prévoit que l'État
reprennent le financement et la gestion
du RSA sur une durée de 5 ans en
contrepartie d'un renforcement des
politiques d'insertion mise en oeuvre
localement cependant la Cour des comptes
juge inefficace de dissocier les
responsabilités financières et
opérationnelles et je souhaiterais avoir
votre sentiment madame le ministre sur
ce sujet et connaître les premiers
retours d'expérience
une autre expérimentation prévoit de
renforcer le contrôle et
l'accompagnement des bénéficiaires du
RSA la Cour des comptes a en effet
pointé les défaillances alarmantes du
dispositif d'accompagnement en matière
de retour à l'emploi seul 40% des
allocataires du RSA bénéficient de la
compagnement social prévu par le dieu
positif et seul un tiers des
allocataires ont un emploi 7 ans après
leur entrée dans le dispositif nous
sommes favorables à un suivi qui soit
enfin efficace il faudra également
s'appuyer sur le principe des droits et
des devoirs pour les bénéficiaires qui
adhèrent alors parcours et qu'il soit
donc moteur de leur insertion
je souhaiterais maintenant formuler
plusieurs remarques sur la politique en
matière de handicap
concernant la location pour Adulte
Handicapé une hausse de 750 millions
d'euros tient compte des deux mesures
que nous avons votées dans la Loi sur la
protection du pouvoir d'achat la
revalorisation de 4% pour tenez compte
de l'inflation et la déconjuguer les
actions ces dernières mesures obtenues
après un long combat parlementaire
bénéficiera à 160 000 de nous
concitoyens pour un gain moyen de 300
euros mensuels elle permettra surtout
d'assurer l'indépendance financière de
la personne handicapée
celle-ci sera effective le 1er octobre
2023 et peut-être même avant comme vous
l'avez indiqué on audition Madame le
Ministre
en matière d'emploi on peut se réjouir
qu'en 3 ans le taux de chômage des
personnes handicapées soient passées de
19 à 14%. il reste cependant presque
deux fois plus élevé que dans la
population générale
certaines entreprises s'engagent par une
convention classique par faire davantage
de place ou handicap il sent pas
ailleurs que dernièrement les tensions
du marché du travail incite les
entreprises à embaucher des chômeurs en
situation de handicap pourriez-vous nous
en donner quelques confirmations
je dirais enfin que quelques mots sur la
protection juridique des majeurs qui
bénéficient actuellement après de 1
million de personnes souffrant de
troubles psychiques en situation de
handicap ou en perte de l'autonomie
compte tenu des vieillissement de la
population ce dispositif pourrait
concerner jusqu'à 2 millions de
personnes en 2040 certes les crédits
consacrés à cette protection sont en
hausse à 9% afin notamment d'augmenter
les salaires et restaurer l'attractivité
de la profession de mandataires à la
protection juridique des majeurs
cependant les moyens nécessaires sont
largement supérieurs au crédit voté
actuellement près de 6500 mandataires se
partagent plus de 390 000 mesures par an
c'est représentent une charge de 60
mesures par mandataire et ce nombre est
difficilement compatible avec la qualité
du service nécessaire pour assurer une
réelle protection des personnes les plus
vulnérables de notre société c'est
pourquoi je présenterai tout à l'heure
un amendement pour transférer des
crédits en conclusion notre groupe
constate l'évolution des crédits de la
mission et sera favorable merci Madame
merci chers
indépendants pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs spéciaux mes
chers collègues autour de 2 milliards
d'euros de hausse soit 8 % pour la
mission solidarité insertion et égalité
des chances dans le budget pour 2023
c'est à la fois un signe positif et
aussi un marqueur de problèmes plus
profond pour notre société nous
traversons des périodes de crise
importantes la pandémie du covid-19 a
été pour beaucoup de Français le signe
de n'approvision appauvrissement pardon
les menants parfois à des situations
extrêmement difficiles la guerre à
l'Ukraine et les tensions énergétiques
que nous subissons dans un Europe
constitue un nouveau défi beaucoup se
demandent comment ils vont passer
l'hiver ainsi que les hivers prochains
les risques de cette crise sur notre
compétitivité sont visibles le groupe
Les Indépendants dès le 5 octobre
dernier lors d'une question d'actualité
au Gouvernement a alerté sur ce sujet
qui laisse se craindre de nouvelles
délocalisations et des fermetures
d'entreprises la conséquence première
serait des licenciements et de nouvelles
difficultés pour les Français
nous devons absolument préserver notre
tissu entrepreneurial et faire en sorte
que nos entreprises puissent rester sur
notre territoire avec les emplois
qu'elle crée le travail est surtout sa
juste rémunération sont des moteurs au
sein de notre société et doivent
permettre de vivre correctement les
réponses conjoncturelles via la
multiplication des aides exceptionnelles
sont importantes en ces temps de crise
multiples cependant je partage la vie
qu'il faut penser à des évolutions
structurelles nous devons donner des
perspectives aux Français et de l'espoir
dans l'avenir comme l'ont appelé dans
leur rapport les rapporteurs spéciaux
dont je salue le travail nos discussions
en commission des affaires sociales ont
aussi révélé certaines failles de notre
système dans mes travaux j'appréhende de
nombreux sujets via le prisme de la
prévention je crois qu'il faut également
le faire sur les sujets de la solidarité
de l'insertion et de l'égalité des
chances la lutte contre la pauvreté
c'est aussi de trouver des solutions
afin qu'elles ne s'installe pas ce qui
me essentiel sur ce point je crois
beaucoup pendant la formation et un
encadrement qui doit permettre de
reprendre pied dans la vie active et de
ne pas laisser un cercle vicieux
s'installé alors que nous allons
négocier les nouvelles générations de
conventions d'appui à la lutte contre la
pauvreté et l'accès à l'emploi je pense
qu'elles doivent être adaptées au plus
près des problématiques de chaque
territoire pour être efficace je suis
particulièrement attentive à la
situation de nos jeunes nous avons
entendu leurs difficultés très
importantes après la pandémie et
maintenant face à l'inflation et au coût
de l'énergie dans ce cadre je salue les
crédits supplémentaires via le
financement d'un fond pour les nouvelles
solidarités alimentaires cependant comme
beaucoup il me semblerait important dans
la situation actuelle de soutenir plus
directement et donc plus rapidement les
associations dédiées à l'aide
alimentaire les bénévoles font un
travail extraordinaire
malgré les contraintes toujours plus
fortes et malheureusement le nombre
croissant de personnes devant qui
recourir d'après l'Insee cela concerne
entre deux et quatre millions de
personnes je souhaiterais aussi évoquer
le rapport à l'Armand de l'UNICEF et sur
ce point il y a beaucoup à faire
concernant l'enfant un dernier point
pour terminer il faut signaler que les
crédits concernant l'AAH pour 2023
seront les premiers après la réforme de
la décongélisation nous devons redonner
des perspectives aux Français et lutter
contre la pauvreté de manière préventive
il y a tant à accomplir afin de répondre
aux problématiques structurelles de
notre système cependant la hausse des
crédits de cette mission est une bonne
nouvelle et le groupe Les Indépendants
votera en faveur merci chers collègues
la parole est à Madame Mélanie vosgel
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire pour 4 minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues la mission nous
examinons aujourd'hui devrait contenir
les grandes actions de l'État visant à
éradiquer la pauvreté l'exclusion et les
discriminations dans notre pays
certaines propositions budgétaires sont
évidemment bienvenues je pense à
l'augmentation de la location du
handicapé la reconduite des 5000 de
budgets à louer à la lutte contre la
précarité menstruelle depuis l'adoption
de l'amendement de ma collègue Raymond
de pensée mange viole à la loi de
finances 2021 l'augmentation du budget
alloué au 39 19 le lancement de
l'expérimentation territoire 100% accès
au droit ces mesures vont naturellement
dans le bon sens mais la réalité
politique c'est qu'elle n'aimait
principalement pas de vous elles sont en
réalité l'émanation de victoire que nous
avons remporté contre vous
l'augmentation de l'enveloppe de la
hache et due à sa déconjugalisation qui
a été obtenue après une campagne
acharnée des associations contre votre
gouvernement
le budget dédié à la lutte contre la
précarité menstruelle et le maintien
d'un dispositif que nous avions fait
adopter il y a deux ans contre la vie du
gouvernement l'augmentation du budget du
39 19 se situe dans la lignée de votre
renoncement un préaltiser sa gestion
suite également à une forte mobilisation
ce n'est donc pas ici l'expression d'un
projet mais d'arbitrage ponctuel lié à
de ponctuels défaites du reste il n'y a
pas vraiment dans cette mission de
politique volontariste pour réduire la
pauvreté l'exclusion et les
discriminations d'abord le manque de
moyens dédié à la solidarité en France
est affligeant quand on sait qu'il y a
près de 10 millions de pauvres ou une
inflation galopante et des basses
salaires qui stagnent pour lutter
efficacement contre la pauvreté il
aurait fallu ouvrir le RSA aux jeunes de
moins de 25 ans rehausser le RSA et la
hah au niveau du seuil de pauvreté
supprimer les contreparties au RSA pour
lutter contre le non recours et garantir
à chacun le minimum vital
au lieu de ça l'assurance chômage assura
moins bien le RSA sera conditionné vous
obstinez dans une réforme des retraites
anti-rodistributive et injuste le budget
de la prime d'activité est un aveu de
son échec à faire sortir les
travailleurs et travailler à spov de la
précarité le manque de moyens dédié à
l'égalité femme homme est aussi frappant
je relierai donc cette demande des
associations féministes
0,1% du PIB pour lutter contre les
violences subies par 50% de la
population sur l'égalité professionnelle
tellement reste à faire notamment en
menant des politiques visant à faire
l'égalité salariale non pas seulement
dans les entreprises mais entre les
secteurs ensuite nous notons des baisses
de financement justifiées de façon
obscure une baisse de 50% de l'aide à la
vie familiale et sociale des anciens
migrants dans leur pays d'origine au
motif d'un faible recours c'est bien
connu en baissant des aides déjà faibles
on améliore le recours à celle-ci baisse
là encore du budget dédié à la stratégie
interministérielle de prévention et de
la lutte contre la pauvreté des enfants
et des jeunes
on empêchera les enfants pauvres d'être
pauvres en leur retirant l'argent mais
aussi l'extension programmée de la
formation des métiers de la santé et du
soin avec la suppression des
autorisations d'engagement c'est vrai
qu'on a aucun besoin en santé c'est bien
connu et puis lorsque vous augmentez des
budgets on sait pas exactement trop
comment ça va se passer je pense par
exemple au fond pour énormément de
tentation alimentaire durable qui est
une bonne chose la manière dont les 60
millions d'euros vont garantir que les
produits concernés seront réellement
durables et peu clair or l'alimentation
c'est un déterminant majeur de la santé
et c'est quasiment exclusivement
dépendant du niveau social plus on est
pauvre moins on a accès à des produits
sains plus on est malade et tout ceci
dans un système où l'alimentation
fournie au plus pauvre et qui les rend
malades rend aussi malades notre planète
pour toutes ces raisons et ayant pesé le
pour et les contre le geste s'abstiendra
sur les crédits de cette mission merci
la parole est à Monsieur Xavier
iacovelli pour le groupe rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants pour 4 minutes
vous savez
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues dans ce
projet de loi de finance 2023 la mission
solidarité insertion à l'égalité des
chances cela date de moyen conséquents
pour la mise en œuvre de plusieurs
chantiers prioritaires dans la
continuité de ce qui a été entreprise
dans les précédentes lois de finances en
termes de politiques sociales de
nombreux sujets d'importance sont
concernés par cette mission je pense
notamment au financement attribué en
matière de protection de l'enfance
inhérents à son bon fonctionnement et à
son organisation le groupement d'intérêt
public France en France protéger sera
mise en oeuvre au 1er janvier 2023 ce
nouveau Jeep s'appuiera sur une
gouvernance associant l'État les
départements mais aussi les
représentants des associations nous
l'avions voté en début d'année et je me
félicite que cette année de ce clôture
par l'examen de crédit permettant son
financement je tiens ici à souligner les
moyens mobiliser pour la protection de
l'enfance afin de répondre à la
diversité des situations difficiles
auxquelles ils doivent faire face
7,4 millions permettront de financer le
plan de lutte contre les violences
faites aux enfants afin de financer
notamment l'unité pardon d'accueil
pédiatrique enfant en danger 140
millions pour la mise en oeuvre de la
stratégie de prévention et de protection
de l'enfance à travers la
contractualisation avec les départements
afin de sécuriser leur parcours des
enfants protégés de fluidifier
l'accompagnement scolaire mais également
de faciliter l'accès au logement et au
droit des jeunes sortant de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance je souhaite revenir
sur un constat que j'avais fait devant
vous depuis maintenant deux ans chaque
année des milliers de jeunes sont
victimes de sortie sèches faute de
Contrat Jeune majeure et
d'accompagnement des départements les
chiffres sont d'ampleur 70% des jeunes
de la Zeus sortent sans diplôme 40% des
100 domicile fixes de moins de 25 ans
ont eu un parcours à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance ainsi c'est pour moi essentiel
que soit mise en oeuvre des mesures pour
faire face à cette situation et c'est ce
que nous avons fait lors de l'examen de
la loi relative à la protection de
l'enfance
aujourd'hui le budget que nous avons qui
nous est soumis prévoit 50 millions pour
fléchir pour prévenir les sorties sèches
des jeunes majeurs de la zone je ne peux
que me satisfaire de voir ce financement
assurer sa mise en place et sa mise en
œuvre ce projet de loi de finance porte
également un financement à l'aide
d'alimentaire abondé en 2023 de 60
millions supplémentaires améliorer la
qualité de l'offre et s'assurer que tous
les moyens soient déployés pour lutter
contre la précarité alimentaire se
devait être au cœur de notre action la
mission solidarité prévoit également le
financement de mesure de lutte contre la
précarité menstruelle qui concerne
environ 1,7 millions de femmes
l'enveloppe de 4,7 millions assura la
distribution de protection aux
populations précaires la collecte et la
redistribution par des associations mais
aussi la sensibilisation de la
population la mission porte également
sur le financement de la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes grande
cause du quinquennat avec notamment une
hausse de près de 15% des crédits pour
répondre aux enjeux multiples en termes
d'accueil d'orientation des victimes et
leur mise en sécurité à travers
plusieurs mesures
la mission solidarité insertion égalité
des chances comporte également le
financement de la location adulte
handicapé dont l'augmentation des
crédits depuis 2017 marque l'engagement
du gouvernement les crédits permettront
de financer la décongélation de la hache
que nous avons voté cet été nous portons
aujourd'hui également avec mes collègues
à Sani et Mohamed souni un amendement
visant à harmoniser les modalités
d'accès à la hache à Mayotte et le
territoire national en proposant
d'étendre la décongélation des
conjugalisation pardon de la hache sur
le territoire Mahoré mais également de
supprimer l'obligation de résidence d'un
an pour pouvoir y prétendre
la mission illustre la volonté du
gouvernement d'assurer pleinement
l'égalité des chances elle démontre
l'ampleur des moyens mis en oeuvre pour
poursuivre les actions de solidarité
engagées ces dernières années elle porte
enfin une réalité derrière des mots des
petits pas et des grandes avancées pour
protéger nos concitoyens dès leur plus
jeune âge de la violence de la précarité
et d'exclusion notamment face à ces
enjeux d'envergure les crédits proposés
nous semblent adéquats pour assurer la
mise en oeuvre d'une politique publique
ambitieuse dans le domaine et c'est
pourquoi le groupe R dti contiendra
pleinement les mesures et l'orientation
de cette mission la parole est à Madame
Annie le héros pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains pour 6
minutes chers collègues
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
ministres chers collègues
depuis ce début d'année la guerre en
Ukraine et ses conséquences de la crise
énergétique angoisse les Français selon
les derniers chiffres du cabinet iris
publié dans le monde l'inflation atteint
11,96 % et dépasse même les 12% sur le
sol rayon alimentaire en novembre dont
16,9% sur les produits frais les
inégalités sociales se creusent 20% des
personnes les plus modestes disposent en
2019 de 8,7% des richesses alors que les
20% les plus élevés en personne en
perçoivent
38%. la mission solidarité insertion
égalité des chances que nous examinons
aurait pu être l'occasion de mettre en
place des mesures sociales fortes et
ambitieuses pour lutter efficacement
contre ces inégalités pour 2023 les
crédits alloués à la mission s'élèvent à
29,9 milliards d'euros en progression de
8,3%, il finance principalement l'âge et
la prime d'activité le programme 304
consacré à l'inclusion sociale et à la
protection des personnes voient ses
crédits augmenter à hauteur de
10,08%. cette hausse qui parait
significative est en grande partie liée
au financement de la réponse à l'urgence
engendrée par la crise économique et
sociale actuelle et sont loin de couvrir
l'inflation dans le cadre de ce
programme l'action 14 dédiée à l'aide
alimentaire étant hausse de 106,7%
mauvaise nouvelle car le nombre de
bénéficiaires augmente l'aide
alimentaire en France concerne 5,5
millions de personnes un chiffre
sous-estimé par rapport aux besoins
réels la demande d'aide alimentaire
restant une démarche difficile et mal
connue sur ces 5,5 millions de personnes
le réseau des Banques Alimentaires
permet d'aider 2 millions de personnes
face à la flambée des prix mais aussi à
l'explosion du nombre de bénéficiaires
la Fédération française des Banques
Alimentaires nous alerte et craint de ne
pas faire face à la demande le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
proposera une augmentation des crédits
alloués à l'aide commentaires et en
particulier pour le soutien aux
initiatives de solidarité alimentaire
territorialisées l'action 19 qui
concerne la stratégie interministérielle
il y a de prévention et de lutte contre
la pauvreté des enfants et des jeunes
s'élèvent à 252 millions pour 200 pour
2023 soit une baisse de 23 % par rapport
à 2022 nous déplorons cette baisse
regrettable et inquiétante quand on sait
que 3 millions d'enfants vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté soit un enfant sur
cinq dans notre pays il y a donc plus
qu'urgence à agir pour que chaque enfant
en France vive et grandissent dignement
nous proposerons donc un amendement pour
augmenter les crédits à louer à cette
action et pour donner à la politique de
protection de l'enfance les moyens de
ses ambitions nous proposons également
un amendement pour abroger les règles
restrictives d'accès au RSA jeune et
ainsi à l'ouvrir au 18-25 ans cette
mesure constituerait un filet de
sécurité efficace pour ces jeunes qui
subissent un taux de chômage à plus du
double de de la moyenne du fait de
problèmes de formation de mobilité une
réponse aux étudiants qui viennent
rallonger les files d'attente de l'aide
alimentaire
s'agissant du programme 157 qui concerne
le handicap et la dépendance 14
milliards d'euros ils sont consacrés
pour 2023 une hausse qui tient compte de
la déconjugalisation de la location
adulte handicapée et de la
revalorisation de celle-ci à hauteur de
4%. acté dans le projet de loi mesure
d'urgence pour le pouvoir d'achat mesure
que nous avons largement soutenu
néanmoins le montant moyen servi aux
allocataires de la hache atteint selon
l'adresse
759 euros sur une base de 1 28 millions
d'allocataires
cela signifie que la grande majorité des
allocataires de la hache vit en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté évalué à 1102 euros
alors que cette allocation est censée
leur permettre de vivre dans la dignité
nous proposerons donc d'augmenter cette
allocation pour qu'elle atteigne le sol
le seuil de pauvreté s'agissant du
programme 137 qui coordonne les actions
relatives à l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes il est en hausse de 54,4
avec
54,4 millions d'euros de crédits à louer
l'action 25 de ce programme finance la
prévention et la lutte contre les
violences et la prostitution pour 2023
les crédits à louer à cette mission
s'élève à 29 millions d'euros soit une
hausse de
17,54%. 1,6 millions d'euros sont
alloués à la lutte contre la
prostitution dont 200 000 euros pour
accroître le nombre de bénéficiaires de
l'aide financière à l'insertion
professionnelle la fils
s'élève à 330 euros par mois là encore
comme pour la hache ce montant est trop
fait pour aider les personnes en
situation de prostitution à en sortir et
amener une nouvelle vie nous proposons
donc de revaloriser cette aide à hauteur
du montant de revenus de solidarité
active c'est-à-dire 598,14
nous saluons cette hausse globale du
programme 137 consacré à l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes mais elle ne
permet pas de répondre aux besoins
nécessaires pour lutter contre les
inégalités de genre ni pour créer par
exemple un observatoire de féminicit qui
est tant attendu il conviendrait de
redoubler d'efforts de financement au vu
de l'ampleur des besoins et d'une
priorité du quinquennat les ressources
nécessaires aux associations qui œuvrent
de son dans ce domaine sont trop limités
c'est pourquoi nous demandons une
augmentation des crédits à hauteur de 1
milliard qui correspond au budget
supplémentaire nécessaire et évalué par
les associations qui se battent au
quotidien pour lutter contre les
violences s'étoffanes globalement les
crédits alloués à cette mission
solidarité insertion égalité des chances
demeure largement insuffisants et ne
permettront pas à nos concitoyens les
plus vulnérables de vivre dignement et
d'espérer un jour sortir de cette
précarité en guise de conclusion je vous
citerai la phrase de Louise Michel en
1871 s'il y a des miséraux de la société
c'est que la société dans laquelle nous
vivons est mal organisé on ne peut pas
admettre qu'il y ait encore des gens qui
crèvent la fin quand d'autres ont des
millions
c'est une pensée qui me révolte
d'actualité la parole est à Madame Cathy
poli pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste pour 4
minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur les co-rapporteurs mes chers
collègues avec près de 30 milliards
d'euros les crédits de la mission
progressent de 2 milliards d'euros par
rapport à 2022 l'examen des crédits en
faveur des personnes les plus fragiles
dans un contexte social extrêmement
préoccupant avec un fort taux de chômage
avec plus de 10 millions de personnes
pauvres et un taux d'inflation de plus
de 6% doit nous alerter les prix flambes
et les pertes ton pouvoir d'achat se
considérable pour une large majorité de
la population les indicateurs sont au
rouge pourtant le gouvernement refuse de
regarder cette réalité en face il refuse
d'augmenter le SMIC de rétablir l'impôt
sur la fortune ou de taxer les super
profits l'augmentation des inégalités
sociales dans notre pays entre les plus
riches et les plus précaires portent un
coup de canif à notre pacte social face
à la crise de le gouvernement a été
capable de débloquer 200 milliards
d'euros pour les entreprises et
aujourd'hui alors que des millions de
familles peuvent basculer dans la
précarité ou la grande précarité
seulement 2 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires seront versés aux
personnes handicapées aux jeunes sans
emploi et aux personnes vulnérables les
crédits de la mission progressent
principalement en raison de la
revalorisation anticipée des prestations
sociales de 4% intervenus au 1er juillet
2022 alors que le nouveau de l'inflation
sur l'année 2022 approche les 5%. cela
veut dire que les ménages les plus
précaires ont perdu du pouvoir d'achat
en 2022 le niveau de l'inflation est
qualifié par la Banque de France de
jamais vu depuis les années 1980 cela
mérite un investissement public à la
hauteur des besoins ce qui n'est
malheureusement pas le cas notre groupe
ayant déposé des amendements sur cette
mission je concentrerai mon propos sur
les jeunes et les moyens de contrôle des
agences régionales de santé comment
pouvons nous satisfaire des crédits de
la stratégie interministérielle de
prévention et de lutte contre la
pauvreté des enfants et des jeunes quand
l'Insee indique que dans notre pays près
de 3 millions d'enfants vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté selon l'Unicef que
8000 enfants vivent dans des bidons
villes l'État doit assurer à toutes et
tous les moyens de vivre dignement et en
particulier à nos jeunes nous savons des
milliers de jeunes de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance sont obligés de dormir à
l'hôtel en raison de la suffisance des
moyens d’état ces jeunes subissent la
violence des réseaux de prostitution et
de raquettes il faut donc plus de moyens
pour mieux les protéger pour nos anciens
ce n'est guère meilleur le gouvernement
se vante d'augmenter les crédits de
personnels de contrôle des EHPAD des
agences régionales de santé après
l'affaire hors pa mais les 51
inspectrices et inspecteurs qui sont
recrutés en 2023 ne remplaceront pas les
2000 postes supprimés depuis 2010
400 entre 2014 et 2021 en 20 ans la
politique de réduction personnelle a
entraîné une baisse de 30% des effectifs
des corps d'inspection et une baisse de
39% des médecins inspecteurs le
renforcement des contrôles
nécessiteraient de revoir à la hausse
les moyens des agences régionales de
santé pour compenser ses pertes mais
aussi pour renforcer les effectifs des
conseils départementaux chargés du
financement des EHPAD l'avancée
concernant la décongivalisation de la
hache pour laquelle nous nous sommes
battus nous et que nous saluons ne
contrevalence malheureusement pas les
mesures négatives que je viens d'évoquer
pour l'ensemble de ces raisons notre
groupe Vatra contre les crédits de la
mission pour 2023 je vous en remercie
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Alain Dufour
pour le groupe Union centriste et pour 6
minutes
sans occulter cependant que les Flaction
ressentie par les populations les plus
fragiles dépassent le taux d'inflation
constatée toutefois comme le souligne le
rapporteur des crises successives
mettent en lumière la vulnérabilité de
notre modèle social lui-même le budget
de l'État ne pouvant l'absorber les
chocs sociaux les interventions répétées
en cours de gestion souligne le défaut
durant le stabilisateur de notre système
de prestation de solidarité
les enseignements direz-vous de ces
crises successives et quelles réponses
pérennes aux urgences sociales
allez-vous apporter sur les quatre
programmes de la mission le programme
304 a pris une activité pourra me 157
avec la location à lutte handicapée sont
les deux postes principaux de la mission
représentant les trois quarts de crédit
la loi sur le pouvoir d'achat d'août
2022 a prévu la
déconjugalisation je vais y arriver de
la hache évolution soutenu de longue
date par le Sénat et initialement contre
le gouvernement celle-ci
le 1er octobre 2023 le programme 157
handicap et dépendance contribuant
également à soutenir les établissements
et services d'aide par le travail à
hauteur d'un milliard et demi qu'on a
une os suivent 6,4 % notamment par
l'augmentation du SMIC et 2023 verra à
la réalisation des mesures bienvenue au
plan de notre transformation des esates
dans un contexte économique des plus
difficiles pour nos concitoyens toucher
par la hausse du prix de l'énergie et
des données alimentaires qui s'ajoutent
à la crise post-covite je voudrais
souligner la question majeure de l'aide
alimentaire en effet au lendemain des
collectes de Dôme pour les banques
alimentaires auxquelles nous sommes
nombreux sur ces bancs à avoir participé
dans nos territoires nous avons pu
mesurer l'inquiétude sur les capacités
de générosité des Français
l'augmentation des ménages les plus
précaires les associations d'aide
alimentaire de plus en plus sollicités
voient le profil des bénéficiaires
évolués étudiant personne seul
travailleur modeste cette personne
survie sont les femmes la demande
d'augmenter de 9% au premier semestre de
1022 pour les banques alimentaires et de
15% pour les Restos du Coeur selon les
chiffres de la commission
l'approvisionnement constitue également
une inquiétude en raison de la hausse
des prix de l'énergie qui touche
singulièrement les associations et des
tensions sur les machines agricoles
depuis les débuts de la guerre à
l'Ukraine l'augmentation des fonds
européens dédiés à l'aide alimentaire le
FSE plus doté de 647 millions d'euros
sur la programmation 2022 2027 et
fragilisée par l'inflation et la
multiplication de l'OM fructué privant
les associations de volumes de denrées
de 70 millions d'euros depuis 2021
certes commence à loi de finance
rectificative pour 40 millions d'euros
quelle mesure comptez-vous mettre en
oeuvre pour améliorer
l'approvisionnement et simplifier les
procédures qui font peser un cadre
normatif très contraignant sur les
associations le fond pour les nouvelles
solidarité alimentaire qui doit être
créée en 2023 avec un volet national et
un volet territorial pour développer les
réseaux les solidarités alimentaires et
les liens avaient les producteurs locaux
est encore incertain pouvez-vous nous
préciser le calendrier et les modalités
de fonctionnement enfin à ce qui
concerne le programme 137 égalité entre
les femmes et hommes représentant une
part modeste la mission je tiens
souligné la hausse des crédits de 14%
par rapport à 2022 et l'on doublement
depuis 2019 la priorité donnée à la
prévention et la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes l'accueil
élève à la mobilité des victimes le
renforcement du réseau d'écoute et la
plateforme téléphonique sont autant
d'appui au programme mon groupe
parlementaire soutient pleinement ces
mesures dans la proposition de loi de
valider Valérie Lietard a été opté le
mois dernier
de ma collègue en aiguillon présidente
la délégation au droit des femmes nous
avons déposé les amendements appelant un
revaloriser la subvention à louer au
centre d'information sur les droits des
femmes et des familles et l'ensemble des
métiers financiers par le programme
aussi dans ces conditions le groupe
Union centriste votera les crédits de
cette mission qui vise à lutter contre
la précarité réduire les inégalités et
protéger les personnes les plus
vulnérables je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est à Madame Bassa
pour 3 minutes
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
ministres messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues dans cette période de
crise économique et sociale que nous
traversons il est important d'avoir un
regard particulier
sur cette mission les chiffres nous les
avons devant les yeux et nous les
connaissons plutôt que de se réjouir
dans un budget s'élevant à 29,9
milliards d'euros pour 2023 j'aimerais
comprendre pourquoi le programme 137
portant sur l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes n'est pas plus importants
d'ailleurs vu la diversité des sujets de
cette mission je m'attarderai plutôt sur
l'égalité femme homme les enjeux sont
immenses comment t'expliquer que dans
notre société encore aujourd'hui des
femmes meurent parce qu'elles sont des
femmes depuis le début de l'année 2022
il y a 821 féminicides dont 62 conjugaux
les moyens accordés sont certes en
hausse mais demeure insuffisantes même
Emmanuel Macron vendredi dernier avoué
je le cite qu'on pouvait faire mieux
pour lutter contre les violences
conjugales il y a quelques semaines je
rendais visite à l'association alt aide
aux femmes battues je rencontrais un
personnel associatif était bénévoles
incroyables engagés et prêt à tout pour
aider ces femmes brisées toutes les
associations de violences faites aux
femmes vous réclament depuis plusieurs
années déjà le milliard ce à quoi vous
répondez par une non augmentation des
crédits alloués au dispositif du 39 19
alors même que la fédération nationale
solidarité femme qui gère le numéro
d'appel a fait état du noces de 14% des
appels par rapport à 2019
où est donc votre logique budgétaire et
votre promesse de faire de la cause des
femmes votre priorité la crise
inflationniste ne distingue pas les gens
certes mais force est de constater que
l'impasse l'inflation impacte plus
grandement les femmes que les hommes
elle représente près de 64% des
recourant à l'aide alimentaire et 72% de
ceux qui recourent au colis et aux
épiceries sociales
ajoutons à cela que les femmes
représentent environ trois quarts des
bas salaire en effet de toutes les
personnes touchant le SMIC en France 62%
sont des femmes c'est très révélateur de
notre modèle social et cela demande une
nouvelle fois que nous sommes loin de
répondre à l'exigence égalité
homme-femme pourtant garantie par notre
Constitution depuis car 1946 mesdames
les ministres le combat les inégalités
salariales et sociales n'est pas dépassé
et mérite d'être accentuée par plus
d'efforts plus de moyens et plus
d'ambition je maintiendrai merci chers
collègues la parole est à monsieur
Jean-Yves roux pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues en janvier dernier le
président de la République déclaré une
douzons lutter contre un arancinement de
la pauvreté qui est ainsi une peur du
quotidien et autres tous perspectives
d'avenir c'est dans cet esprit que la
mission solidarité insertion égalité des
chances mobilisent des crédits
indispensables pour affronter les crises
et assurer au plus fragile d'entre nous
une certaine dignité en 2023 les crédits
de la mission augmentent et atteignent
un peu plus de 29 milliards d'euros
notamment pour accompagner les mesures
contre l'inflation telle que la
revalorisation de 4% des aides sociales
ou la déconjugualisation de la location
aux adultes handicapés mais dans ce
contexte social préoccupant la question
du Nord au cours de prestation sociale
et prégnante aussi il me paraît plus que
jamais indispensable d'aller chercher
celle et ceux qui ne savent pas celles
et ceux qui renoncent face à la
complexité ou l'électronisme
des campagnes mieux ciblées et plus
volontaires s'imposent en 2021 25% des
plus jeunes l'ont pas eu accès à une
aide à laquelle ils avaient droit
expérimentation des territoires 100%
accès aux droits permettra je l'espère
d'enrichir notre arsenal de lutte contre
le Nord recours mais je pense que nous
devons nous diriger vers une
automatisation des premiers versements
quand cela est possible vers des
déclarations et des guichets uniques
pleinement décentralisés et contrôlable
les politiques publiques de la
solidarité s'en trouveraient renforcés
mes chers collègues vous me
permettraient trois remarques sur des
programmes spécifiques de la mission
concerner l'allocation du handicapé ne
nous félicitons de rentrer en Rico de la
déconjugalisation de la hache même si
celle-ci n'interviendra qu'en octobre
2023 nous regrettons que nous
amendements visa revaloriser le montant
de la lâche au moins au moins au niveau
de seuil de pauvreté était déclaré et
recevable
deuxième remarque la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes connaît une
augmentation de 14% avec un particulier
la mise en oeuvre du pack nouveau départ
proposé aux femmes qui doivent être
accompagnées pour une nouvelle vie or
les femmes victimes de violences
conjugales en millions orales sont les
grandes oubliés de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes elle souffre
d'un isolement à la fois géographique et
morale qui les fragilise en plus encore
une enquête régionale montre ainsi 50%
des féminicides survenus un nouvel
Aquitaine aurait lieu dans ces zones
rurales ou neuvie pourtant qu'un tiers
de la population de la région 600
000 euros des dips pour 2023 à ces
actions dans la réalité ne sont pas à
mon sens tout à fait à la hauteur de la
protection du à ces femmes dernière
remarque alors que les banques
alimentaires viennent d'assurer un
week-end de collecte plus difficile que
prévu et que le rapport de l'IGF de
novembre 2022 atteste d'une hausse des
produits alimentaires de 10% à 12% en
décembre
d'urgence et bien là les boucliers
associatifs et des collectivités locales
ne peuvent prendre le relais car la
vague est trop forte or la question du
chèque alimentaire durable et sur la
table depuis le 3 novembre 2022 le fond
pour une aide alimentaire durable de 60
millions d'euros souhaité par la
première ministre devait être géré à
travers des projets locaux nous
demandons que cette mesure annoncée
puisse aller vite je souhaiterais
également que ces chèques puissent être
utilisés pour payer la restauration
collective et des cantines scolaires
permettant ainsi aux enfants les plus
fragiles d'avoir au moins un repas
équilibré par jour au delà de ces
remarques notre groupe votera cette
mission budgétique je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Catherine Belletti pour le groupe
les républicains et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la mission
solidarité insertion et égalité des
chances du PLF de 20023 et doté de 29,8
milliards d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement et 29,9 milliards d'euros
en crédit de paiement ces crédits sont
respectivement en hausse de 1,8
milliards d'euros et de 2,3 milliards
d'euros par rapport au crédit ouvert en
loi de finance initiale pour 2021 cette
mission regroupe 4 programmes importants
l'inclusion sociale et protection des
personnes ou les crédits de la prime
d'activités augmentent d'un milliard
handicap et dépendance dans les crédits
augmentent de 6% et supportent notamment
le coût de la déconjugalisation de la
location aux autres handicapés égalité
femme homme dont l'augmentation de
14,95% sert notamment renforcé la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
et améliorer passer au droit ce qu'il
faut saluer conduite et soutien des
politiques sanitaires et sociales dont
la dotation supporte en partie la hausse
du point d'indice de la fonction
publique et la valorisation du schéma
d'emploi pour 2023 la généralisation de
ces augmentations s'explique par le rôle
d'avant-garde de cette mission
budgétaire face à la crise sanitaire et
sociale que nous avons traversé sur
laquelle nous ne reviendrons pas ici en
revanche les dépenses exceptionnelles
alimentent d'autant plus cette
augmentation dans le contexte de la
crise économique actuelle marquée par
une hausse généralisée des prix la
hausse budgétaire de cette mission
poursuit donc son ascension en 2023 à
partir d'objectifs très hétérogène
tantôt structurel est lié à des
objectifs de long terme de nos
politiques publiques telles que la lutte
contre la précarité la recentralisation
du revenu solidarité active l'égalité
femme homme et la protection de
l'enfance
tantôt ponctuel est destinée à protéger
le pouvoir d'achat des français tantôt
aux circonstanciels et dépendant
exceptionnel tels que la revalorisation
anticipée des minima sociaux de 400
millions et l'aide d'exceptionnelles de
rentrée de plus d'un milliard actons
tout d'abord que les crédits à louer à
la prime d'activité et à la location aux
adultes handicapés représentent
l'essentiel des crédits de la mission
pour 66,8 %. la prime d'activité qui a
remplacé la prime pour l'emploi ainsi
qu'une partie du revenu de solidarité
active soutient le pouvoir d'achat des
travailleurs modestes à hauteur de 10
milliards pour près de 4,6 millions de
foyers la location aux adultes
handicapés bénéficie quant à elle d'un
dynamisme structurel lié au
vieillissement démographique et à
l'extension de la reconnaissance du
handicap mais il faut souligner le poids
de la déconjugalisation de cette
allocation enfin adoptée
en revanche l'augmentation générale et
continue des crédits de cette mission
subit le coût des mesures
exceptionnelles qui requiert une
vigilance accrue plan d'urgence en
matière alimentaire d'enfance de
violence conjugales si ajoutent
notamment l'indemnité inflation des 1000
euros à toute personne percevant de
moins de 2000 euros de revenus nets
mensuels et des aides exceptionnelles
dont on ne dressera pas la liste ici
quatre dispositifs exceptionnels se sont
succédés en moins de deux ans or ces
dépenses ponctuelles sont directement
imputables à une politique du chèque
laquelle ne parvient pas à dissimuler ce
que nos collègues rapporteurs Arnaud
Bazin et Eric Bocquet ont éloque appelé
des fragilités à double titre d'une part
fragilité du rôle de l'État qui ne
serait ce borné à absorber de manière
exceptionnelle mais surtout perpétuel
des chocs sociaux et économiques
d'autre part fragilité de l'intervention
de l'État qui s'est trop souvent abstenu
de politique structurelles en
particulier à l'égard du chômage du
sous-emploi et de la faiblesse des
salaires en conclusion nous voudrions
donc insister sur la vie vigilance dû au
budget de cette mission dont
l'augmentation marquerait l'apparition
d'un état amortisseur et dont les
politiques publiques se réduiraient au
poids budgétaire d'une politique du
chèque
il faut bien au contraire tourner nos
travaux vers la l'élaboration de
politique de long terme nous voudrions
souligner les formes budgétaires à
poursuivre concernant l'égalité femme
homme d'une part et d'autre part le
financement du futur groupement
d'intérêts publics France en France
protégé celui-ci a fait l'objet des
amendements salutaires des commissions
des finances et des affaires sociales du
Sénat je vous remercie
merci chers collègues alors nous allons
donner la parole à mesdames les
ministres je vous rappelle que vous avez
un temps global de 10 minutes maximum à
vous partager et que bien entendu je
couperai la parole à la dernière donc le
décompte part à 10 minutes et je donne
la parole à Madame Geneviève dariussec
ministre délégué chargé des personnes
handicapées
merci madame la Présidente
les ministres
monsieur les rapporteurs mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
ce premier examen des crédits de la
mission solidarité insertion et égalité
des chances se mobilisent trois
ministères cela montre l'importance des
politiques qu'elle finance qui
permettent de mener des actions
concrètes en matière de lutte contre la
pauvreté de réduction des inégalités de
protection des personnes vulnérables en
conciliant le cours et le long terme
dans un contexte où le coût de la vie
pèse sur nos concitoyens nous avons fait
le choix de protéger ceux d'entre eux
qui sont les plus fragiles avec les
crédits de cette mission en hausse de
7,8% pour 2023 soit plus de 2 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires et le programme
304 inclusion sociale et protection des
personnes voit son budget augmenter de
près de 1 milliard deux
cette hausse permet de financer la
revalorisation de 4% des prestations
sociales que vous aviez voté à notre
dernier ainsi que la montée en puissance
de la prime d'activité mais elle acte
aussi la création du fond pour l'aide
alimentaire durable doté de 60 millions
d'euros qui vise à réduire l'impact
environnemental tout en faisant de
l'aide alimentaire un outil central de
lutte contre la pauvreté à court terme
nous avons décidé d'attribuer 7 millions
d'euros supplémentaires pour déployer la
tarification de 1 euro dans les à 1 euro
dans les cantines pardon et cette mesure
sera au cœur du futur pacte des
solidarités la période de forte
inflation nous oblige par ailleurs à des
mesures d'urgence une enveloppe
exceptionnelle a été débloquée à hauteur
de 10 millions d'euros pour financer 300
000 colis alimentaires permettant à une
étudiant de se nourrir pendant une
semaine
autre grande priorité à laquelle je suis
évidemment attaché l'accompagnement des
personnes handicapées ce PLF à Croix de
6,4% soit 845 millions d'euros les
moyennes dédiés à leur accompagnement
sur le programme 175 handicap et
dépendants
parmi les grandes dépenses financées il
y a bien évidemment l'Allocation Adulte
handicapées pour un total de 12
milliards et demi d'euros avec une
hausse de 750 millions d'euros pour
tenir compte de la revalorisation de 4%,
mais aussi de l'individualisation à
venir de la hache autre axe majeure 1
milliard et demi d'euros dédiés à la
garantie de rémunération des
travailleurs handicapés à Nesat ce
budget nous permet de conduire une
réforme structurelle pour fluidifier les
parcours professionnels des personnes
accompagnées en ESAT et nous entendons
encore l'amplifier
et ce budget finançant fin l'emploi
accompagné dispositif auquel je crois
beaucoup et qui est un levier
indispensable pour viser l'amélioration
de l'emploi des personnes en situation
de handicap il apporte le soutien
nécessaire à l'insertion et à leur
maintien dans leur poste de travail
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs je veux pour finir insister
sur l'importance des politiques
financées par cette mission leur impact
est immense dans la vie des Français les
plus vulnérables mais ces politiques ont
aussi beaucoup de sens pour les agents
publics ces hommes et ces femmes qui les
déploient sur le terrain au quotidien il
est indispensable pour le pays que le
secteur social et médico-social
disposent de personnels qui soient
formés à ces enjeux très précis et
qu'ils soient en nombre suffisant c'est
pourquoi la mission solidarité accueille
des moyens supplémentaires dédiés en
cohérence avec ce qui est fait en PLFSS
il de pérenniser des postes cruciaux par
exemple ceux des renforts dédiés à la
crise covid covid afin de pouvoir
capitaliser demain sur des compétences
précieuses en matière de pilotage et de
gestion des crises il s'agit également
de recruter des équipes au sein des ARS
notamment pour renforcer l'émission de
contrôle en EHPAD nous partageons tous
ici la conviction que notre système de
soie et de solidarité repose d'abord sur
les hommes et les femmes qui s'engagent
auprès de leurs compatriotes les plus
vulnérables je vous remercie merci la
parole est à madame Isabelle Rome
ministre délégué chargé de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes de la
diversité et de l'égalité des chances
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres messieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le président de la
commission des finances madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs programme de
l'égalité avec un E majuscule le
programme 137 dont j'ai la
responsabilité s'articule autour de
trois axes forts la lutte contre les
violences l'égalité économique et
professionnelle et la culture de
l'égalité permettez-moi tout d'abord de
me réjouir de la hausse du budget dédié
au ministère dont j'ai la responsabilité
cette progression s'élève à 7,3 millions
d'euros dans le cas du projet de loi
initiale ce qui représente 15%
supplémentaires par rapport à 2022 pour
atteindre 57,9 millions d'euros
l'augmentation du p137 s'inscrit dans un
continuum depuis 2017 au total en 5 ans
le programme 137 aura progressé de plus
de
95%, c'est la traduction en acte de la
grande cause des deux du président de la
République ces moyens supplémentaires
permettront notamment de renforcer les
aides aux associations dans le cas du
PLF 2023 un effort budgétaire important
d'un million 6 sera ainsi consacré au
réseau de la sncidf pour atteindre 6,3
millions d'euros
600000 euros de crédit supplémentaire
permettront de développer la démarche de
la les Verts si important dans nos
territoires ruraux ou périphériques 3,6
millions d'euros de crédit nouveau
seront consacrés à l'intensification de
la prévention et lutte contre les
violences permettez-moi aussi de
m'arrêter sur le 39 19 la plateforme
d'écoute et d'orientation des victimes
dans le gouvernement a étendu les
horaires 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
un effort supplémentaire de 2,9 millions
d'euros permettra de soutenir l'action
de la FNSF et du dispositif d'écoute en
parallèle les actions de prévention
lutte contre la prostitution seront
renforcées notamment via une
augmentation de 200 000 euros afin
d'accompagner la hausse du nombre des
bénéficiaires de laide financière à
l'insertion professionnelle par ailleurs
le gouvernement propose un abonnement
sur pour ouvrir la compensation du Ségur
ou structure associatives de la branche
de l'action sanitaire et sociale dont
font partie les associations
œuvrant dans le champ de l'égalité femme
homme je l'ai déjà dit à de nombreuses
reprises le financement de l'ensemble
des actions en faveur de l'égalité femme
homme dépasse le simple cadre du
programme 137 comme l'indique le
document politique transversal ce sont
3,3 milliards qui sont alloués la
politique d'égalité du gouvernement
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs je me réjouis que le Sénat se
saisisse avec autant de détermination de
la grande cause des quinquennats du
président de la République un enjeu qui
dépasse élevage partisans je vous
remercie merci
la parole est à Madame Charlotte cobel
secrétaire d'État chargé de l'enfance
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames les ministres monsieur
les rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs l'enfant c'est une
priorité du gouvernement c'est une
politique éminemment interministérielle
la première ministre a d'ailleurs réuni
la semaine dernière le premier comité
interministériel de l'enfance avec
l'ensemble des ministres concernés nous
avons déterminé 40 mesures structurées
en trois axes lutter contre les
violences faites aux enfants garantir
l'égalité des chances et agir pour le
développement et l'avenir de tous les
enfants sur le plan financier évidemment
les crédits de l'enfance sont portés par
de nombreux ministères mais aussi par
les départements et les collectivités
locales c'est pourquoi je porte dans le
PLF 2023 trois sujets le premier celui
de créer un jaune budgétaire sur
l'enfance le gouvernement a d'ailleurs
porté par amendement à l'Assemblée
nationale ce projet cela me semble
indispensable enfin avoir une vision
complète de l'ensemble des financements
mobilisés par l'État mais aussi par les
collectivités locales la seconde
priorité c'est le maintien des crédits
de la stratégie de prévention et de
protection de l'enfance incluant le
renforcement de la prise en charge des
jeunes majeurs à hauteur de 190 millions
d'euros 2023 sera une année d'évaluation
et d'élargissement de la
contractualisation à des acteurs
essentiels que sont l'éducation
nationale et la justice nous
réfléchissons par ailleurs à la
contractualisation avec des territoires
particulièrement exposés comme les
territoires d'outre-mer ou de la
couronne francilienne
nous avons porté l'augmentation des
emplois avec les autres ministres sur le
terrain pour améliorer le pilotage de
l'action de l'État et des contrôles
c'est le troisième axe qui que je
sollicite c'est une priorité l'État doit
prendre sa place dans l'accompagnement
des départements et plus
particulièrement dans le contrôle des
établissements de protection de
l'enfance c'est donc 31 emplois qui sont
demandés dans les services des dettes
qui s'ajouteront aux vins emploi
sollicités sur une autre mission pour la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse ce
projet dollars de finance a ainsi pour
objectif de consolider et renforcer la
politique de l'enfance aux côtés des
départements des autres collectivités
territoriales et bien sûr des nombreux
acteurs engagés dans cette politique
merci
merci madame la ministre et bravo pour
avoir suivi le timing sincèrement
alors nous allons procéder à l'examen
des amendements portant sur les crédits
de la mission solidarité insertion et
égalité des chances figurantes à l'état
B alors je vous rappelle que pour cette
mission la Conférence des Présidents a
fixé la durée maximum de la discussion à
2h30 et que celle-ci était portée
exceptionnellement hier à 3h30 en
conséquence si nous n'avions pas terminé
l'examen de cette mission à 19h20
celui-ci se poursuivrait à la fin des
missions de cette semaine et nous
passerions à l'examen de la mission
santé en revanche si nous terminions
avant le terme de cette durée l'examen
de la mission suivante pourrait
commencer sans attendre je vous remercie
et nous passons à l'amendement 730
présenté par le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs avant d'ouvrir l'examen des
amendements de fonds déposés sur cette
mission solidarité je vous propose en
ajuster le niveau global pour une
question de sincérité il me semble en
effet important de tenir compte des
dernières prévisions sur lesquelles le
gouvernement s'appuie et des dernières
évolutions actées notamment en lien avec
les collectivités locales je vous
propose ainsi de faire évoluer les
crédits pour 2023 de cette mission à
hauteur de 470 millions d'euros un
niveau substantiel mais qui traduit un
certain nombre d'évolution que je
souhaite détailler tout d'abord une
actualisation des prévisions de la CNAV
en matière de recours à la prime
d'activité et aux revenus de solidarité
active de telles actualisations se somme
toute classique et celle-ci est en
l'occurrence liée à l'amélioration de la
situation du marché du travail observez
ces derniers mois dont nous pouvons je
pense toutes et tous
nous féliciter il ne faut bien sûr y
voir ni triomphalisme alors que nous
venons de continuer à avancer
collectivement vers le plein emploi ni
remise en question des droits des
individus les autres évolutions vont
quant à elle dans le sens d'une
augmentation des crédits avec par
exemple l'entrée du département de
l'Ariège dans l'expérimentation de
recentralisation du RSA pour un montant
de 40 millions d'euros ou encore la
compensation d'une partie des
revalorisations salariales décidées en
février 2022 et supporté par les
départements c'est une soulte de 14
millions d'euros que nous avons discuté
avec les départements dans le cadre du
comité des financeurs donc nous
inscrivons dans ce texte et enfin une
revalorisation
salariale de 3% pour tous les opérateurs
relevant de la branche de l'action
sanitaire et sociale donc le secteur
privé non lucratif financé par cette
mission revalorisation qui est
équivalente à celle de l'augmentation du
point d'indice dans la fonction publique
donc pour 38
millions d'euros toutes ces ouvertures
de crédit sont indispensables pour que
l'État puisse tenir ses engagements en
matière de prestation sociale de
revalorisation salariale ou de
recrutement d'agents publics
l'amendement qui vous est proposé montre
donc bien à mon sens tant la
responsabilité que l'ambition de ce
gouvernement au moment de finaliser le
budget de l'État pour 2023
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
merci Madame le présidente mesdames les
ministres monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues l'impact à la baisse des
crédits vous l'avez cité monsieur le
ministre de l'ordre de 470 millions
d'euros principalement dû à la révision
des prévisions que nous ne sommes pas en
mesure d'expertiser mais qui engage
votre gouvernement en tout état de cause
le RSA la prime d'activités ont des
droits ouverts j'aurais tendance à dire
que peu importe les montants inscrits de
toute façon ces droits devront être
servis cependant je souhaitais vous
interroger sur les 14 millions d'euros
que vous avez évoqués au titre de la
soulte due au département après la
conférence des métiers de
l'accompagnement social et médico-social
si cette somme semble conforme à ce
qu'attendre des départements ceux-ci
souhaite toutefois connaître les
modalités de la répartition de cette
somme si vous pouvez nous la préciser de
toute façon ce sera un avis de sagesse
de la Commission
merci monsieur le ministre
oui je peux répondre immédiatement
la répartie le mode de répartition de
cette somme leur appartient puisque nous
avons décidé avec ma collègue Charlotte
cobel lorsque nous avons réuni le comité
des financeurs qui leur appartiendrait
de définir dans le cadre de l'Assemblée
des départements de France la
répartition de l'enveloppe je crois
qu'il y avait un débat entre un mode
forfaitaire ou un mode au réel de la
répartition de cette enveloppe merci
alors je vais mettre au voile amendement
du gouvernement qui a reçu un avis de
sagesse de la commission qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est donc adopté
34 amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement 422 Monsieur Roux
merci
en France on compte plus de 3 millions
de personnes nouvellement de chaque
année un quart des deuil se complique ou
deviennent pathologique les conséquences
sanitaires sociales économiques du seuil
sont lourds pour l'individus comme pour
la société dans cet amendement propose
de développer une politique publique de
prévention des risques liés au deuil et
de le doter de nouveaux crédits permet
d'offrir un accompagnement psychologique
adapté aux personnes en deuil qui le
souhaitent de former les professionnels
à un meilleur accompagnement
vous pouvez continuer Monsieur Roux et
le deuxième c'est un amendement de repli
l'amendement 534 madame le wérou madame
meunier merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre mesdames les
ministres c'est amendement visa doté
dignement notre politique de protection
de l'enfance par des moyens en lui
donnant les moyens de ses ambitions les
dépenses par rapport au montant
d'autorisation d'engagement et de crédit
de paiement proposé par le gouvernement
dans l'action 19
ont diminué et ça ne peut être accepté
d'autant que la protection de l'enfance
va mal et on lui demande de plus en plus
la loi de 2022 demande à juste titre
d'accompagner les mineurs jusqu'à l'âge
de 21 ans par les Conseils
départementaux l'inscription en priorité
pour obtenir un logement social etc or
le besoin principal remonté par les
acteurs du terrain que ce soit en maison
d'enfants à caractère social ou dans les
familles
nous disent le besoin de moyens
supplémentaires moyen d'investissement
bien sûr mais surtout moyen humain des
éducateurs des éducatrices notre
amendement repose aussi sur la
conviction que ces 250 millions d'euros
de dépenses supplémentaires proposées
sont des dépenses qui finalement seront
des dépenses d'investissement puisque
dans l'avenir nous aurons moins de
dépenses de santé publique par exemple
ou de politique d'insertion ou d'accueil
des jeunes laissés à l'abandon donc nous
proposons ce prélèvement de 150 millions
sur l'action 17 du programme 124 merci
la maman 424 Monsieur Roux
donc c'est exactement le même que les
deux premiers c'est quand même un
propose donc d'abonder ce nouveau
programme de 200 millions d'euros en
minorant l'action 17 financement des
assurances régionales de santé du
programme 124 conduite et soutien des
politiques sanitaires et sociales et
l'action homme prime 11 prime d'activité
et autres dispositif du programme 304
inclusion sociale et des personnes les
plus chacune de 100 millions 500 000
euros à un acte d'engagement et rien CP
merci
l'amendement 533 madame meunier c'est un
amendement de repli si on peut dire
puisque c'est un amendement qui propose
de doter de 125 millions donc la moitié
de ce que je viens de dire sur la
stratégie interministérielle de
prévention de lutte contre la pauvreté
des enfants et des jeunes merci le 535
c'est même meunier
même le weyrou
défendu je le prends madame la
Présidente le 535 abonda nouveau
programme intitulé fond de prise en
charge psychotroma causé aux enfants
suite à des violences sexuelles et à des
violences intrafamilales à hauteur de
100 millions d'euros la prise en charge
des psychotromaches et l'enfant suite à
des violences sexuelles ou des violences
subies dans le cas de familial est une
politique d'ambition la création d'un
tel fond de prise en charge ne doit pas
être perçue comme une charge nouvelle
mais comme de futurs économies je viens
de le dire pour des budgets de la nation
et des comptes sociaux les conséquences
des traumatismes sont abondamment
décrites chaque année en France 165
000 enfants sont victimes de viol et de
violence
intra-familiales seulement 4% des pauses
plaintes et moins de 1% des plaintes
aboutissent aux assises autrement dit
l'impunité est quasi totale la
réparation est quasi INEX en tout cas
fortement retardé faute de repérage à
temps pourtant le traumatisme les
traumatismes sont réversibles et plus
ils sont pris à temps et précocement et
plus ils ont de chances d'être soignés
guéri ou en tout cas trouver une
certaine résilience si on reste
impuissant face au risque vitaux
encourus il y a également un risque pour
la santé mentale et la santé physique de
ces jeunes futurs adultes voilà pour
l'amendement 538 c'est Madame meunier
même le wérou
[Musique]
alors nous avons trois amendements
identiques alors le premier le 385
monsieur Chassin
présidente madame monsieur le ministre
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames messieurs
donc si vous voulez cette amendement
concerne la protection juridique des
jeunes mains majeurs qui sont près de 1
million de citoyens ont 44 % de
personnes souffrant de troubles
psychiques 30% des personnes en
situation de handicap et 22% sont des
personnes en termes d'autonomie donc la
moitié des mesures de protection
497000 ans en 2020 sont exercées par
8300 mandataires
et donc dans 80% sont salariés de
service associatif
aujourd'hui près de
6500 mandataires judiciaires de
protection de jeunes majeurs des
services associatifs se partagent plus
de 390 000 mesures par an dans 60 chacun
donc le nombre est difficilement
compatible avec le maintien de haut
niveau de qualité pour les personnes
concernées donc afin d'agir concrètement
pour la protection donc juridique et
faire assez constats d'urgence cet
amendement propose d'abonder de 95
millions d'euros la dotation versée par
l'État au service associatif cette
revalorisation devra entériner le
recrutement de 1800 professionnels pour
passer de 60 à 45 mesures gérées par
mandataire judiciaire de protection des
jeunes majeurs
permettant ainsi de baisser la charge de
travail mais surtout de maintenir la
qualité du service donc il est proposé
d'attribuer ces 95 millions de crédits
supplémentaires en faveur de l'action 16
du programme 304 et pour respecter les
règles de recevabilité prise financière
il est proposé une baisse de 47,5
millions sur l'action 12 et de
47,5 millions sur l'action 11 merci
merci
Monsieur Roux pour le 406 il est bien
défendu
merci beaucoup le 658 monsieur Savary il
est très bien défendu monsieur Rickman
il est défendu
oui madame la Présidente effectivement
cet amendement défendu mais je voulais
rajouter quelques points pour le
défendre davantage
pourquoi parce que l'exemple demandé
département la Haute-Saône illustre
parfaitement les conséquences mises en
cause par ce cet amendement si on prend
le cas de la Haute-Saône ou une
désaffection du métier de mandataire
judiciaire à la protection des majeurs
étaient effectivement
des responsabilités en effet ces
mandataires sont aujourd'hui
rémunérés sous le fait de la grille de
la classe de l'arbre convention 66 qui
elle-même ignore le métier de mandataire
et donc ils émargent en tant
qu'éducateur spécialisé ce qui fait
qu'ils sont sous rémunérés rien que pour
vous donner un exemple depuis 2019 sur
les 14 mandataires que compte les
services de la Haute-Saône 10 en
démissionné et sur les recrutements un
seul a pu se faire à travers un
mandataire qualifié ce qui signifie
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de temps et
beaucoup d'argent dépensé pour former de
nouveaux mandataires enfin
les tribunaux nous annonce un
mandattement qui va augmenter la
révision régulière des mesures permet
certes d'adapter des mesures de
protection à l'évolution des situations
mais cela génère un flux entrée et
sortie mal pris en compte avec du retard
dans la tarification les mandataires au
Sauno à suivre à ce jour 53 personnes en
moyenne et nous ne connaîtrons qu'en
juillet de l'année prochaine le montant
du budget accordé et donc si nous ne
pouvons embaucher pour prendre en charge
des mesures supplémentaires acquise
d'ici là
pour conclure les personnels motivés à
la base dans le choix de leur métier par
l'aide aux personnes vulnérables sont en
souffrance de ne pouvoir voir les moyens
de mener à bien leur mission c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai consigné je
vautré cet amendement merci madame la
Présidente merci le 548 madame levure
oui merci madame la Présidente c'était
également un abonnement qui concerne la
protection juridique que des majeurs la
moitié des mesures de protection sont
exercées par 8300 mandataires
judiciaires à la protection des majeurs
donc près de 80% sont salarié des
services associatifs des projections
actuelles montrent un besoin d'anticiper
des conséquences notamment du
vieillissement de la population
aujourd'hui donc près de 6500
mandataires judiciaires à la protection
des majeurs ce partage 390
000 mesures par an soit 60 mesures par
mandataire donc les crédits ne
permettent pas de d'assurer en fait le
besoin qui était évalué à 1800
professionnel supplémentaires qui
devrait être recrutés pour faire face
aux besoins et passer de 60 à 45 mesures
donc ben voilà c'est l'objet de
l'amendement c'est de rétablir ces
crédits merci
l'amendement 60 monsieur mouillé
ministre on est dans le même logique à
une demande de crédit supplémentaire
avec un montant différent peut-être un
peu plus raisonnable à hauteur au regard
des enjeux simplement par cette
intervention c'est surtout pour rappeler
la crise de la situation qui est
extrêmement difficile sur les terrains
beaucoup de maires nous feront monter
des difficultés pour avoir des
interlocuteurs beaucoup de prise en
charge qui sont décalées parfois même
incapacité d'avoir des contacts dans les
structures associatives pourtant qui
essayent de faire un maximum d'efforts
mais elles sont submergées par les
situations et à la fois on a évoqué des
sons de la population mais c'est
également la situation économique et
sociale qui est aujourd'hui de plus en
plus difficile qui entraîne et bien en
complément des problématiques plutôt
psychiques et bien des difficultés sur
les et toi donc la nécessité de la mise
en place de professionnels pour
accompagner ces majeurs à protéger voilà
donc c'est vraiment un cri d'alarme de
la profession c'est également quelque
part un quai des larmes des élus locaux
et avec un grand principe général plus
nous prendrons en considération les
besoins sur le terrain taux moins ça
coûtera à notre société nous sommes dans
un texte budgétaire et je crois qu'il
faut l'entendre merci merci chers
collègues le 537 madame le werrou
le 537 concerne un amendement qui vise à
créer un fonds de soutien pour des
initiatives de solidarité alimentaire
territorialisées la période covid nous a
fait prendre conscience des inégalités
criantes en termes d'accès à une
alimentation durable et de qualité
l'inflation cette année est venue
exacerber cette situation préoccupante
selon les dernières données de l'INSEE
donc l'augmentation des prix
alimentaires et approche les 12% selon
les produits les effets sur la santé
d'un manque d'accès d'accès à une
alimentation de en quantité ou qualité
suffisante sont aujourd'hui bien connues
avec pour conséquence une double peine
pour les ménages en situation de
précarité donc ce fond vise à soutenir
des dynamiques multi partenariale alors
que l'ingénierie l'investissement sont
souvent soutenus par des appels à
projets se font visa soutenir des frais
de lancement mais aussi de
fonctionnement
ingénierie frais d'administration et
surtout toute la dépense liée aux
besoins d'animation et de formation
pour de véritables effets de
participation des personnes madame le
wérou le 549
à 149 concerne la revalorisation de
l'ensemble des métiers financés par le
programme égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes les associations financées
par ce programme se retrouvent exclus du
périmètre de revalorisation salariale je
crois que ça a été revu depuis pour
autant je pense que il faut
impérativement revaloriser ces métiers
pour permettre également à
ces métiers d'être attractif et rémunéré
correctement parce que les métiers du
social est particulièrement pour prendre
en charge les personnes et les femmes
victimes de violence sont
pas suffisant voilà merci amendement
identique 594 même la présidente Lyon
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
chaque année plus de 800.000 femmes sont
écoutées accompagnées hébergées et
soutenu au sein de différentes
structures majoritairement associatives
je pense par exemple aux accueils de
jour spécialisés mais aussi aux lignes
d'écoute pour les victimes sans oublier
les permanences juridiques et sociales
déployées partout en France le programme
137 égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes vise à soutenir l'ensemble des
métiers permettant à ses 800.000 femmes
de recevoir l'aide précieuse dont elles
ont besoin en février 2022 les
associations financées par ce programme
ont été exclus du périmètre des
revalorisations salariales des métiers
du social et du médico-social porté par
l'État lors de la conférence des métiers
or l'absence de mesure de revalorisation
pour l'ensemble de ce secteur menace à
terme la qualité et continuité de
l'accompagnement de ces femmes et de ses
victimes à cela s'ajoute le manque
d'attractivité des métiers du secteur
social toutes catégories confondues ça
entraîne des sous-é effectifs
inquiétants donc ça a été déjà expliqué
donc cette amendement vise donc à
revaloriser l'ensemble des métiers
financés par le programme égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes en généralisant
la prime du Ségur social je vous
remercie merci l'amendement 710 madame
Cohen oui merci madame la Présidente la
mission solidarité prévoit en 2023 une
augmentation de 15% des crédits destinés
à l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes même si nous accueillons avec
satisfaction l'augmentation de des
crédits nous regrettons que s'agissant
de la grande cause du quinquennat le
gouvernement ne maintiennent pas la
progression des crédits en faveur de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
des années précédentes quoi que déjà
insuffisante mais qui était je vous le
rappelle pour 2022 de 22% et pour 2021
de 37 ce regret d'autant plus vif que
dans le détail des actions budgétaires
la ligne pour l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes diminuent en réalité de
1,7%. alors que dans les mots je crois
que nous sommes toutes et tous
convaincus du poids de l'éducation pour
faire progresser l'égalité seulement 4
millions d'euros sont prévus pour
financer des projets territoriaux
destinés notamment à déconstruire les
stéréotypes sexistes et promouvoir la
participation des filles dans les
domaines où elles sont peu représentées
voire invisibiliser par contre 11,4
millions d'euros sont prévus au profit
de l'entrepreneuriat des femmes et du
développement de la culture de l'égalité
dans les entreprises de poids de mesure
pourquoi un tel une telle différence
pour nous ces combats ne sont pas
contradictoires donc notre amendement
d'appel vous invite à revaloriser
l'ensemble des métiers qui sont financés
par le programme égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes en généralisant la
prime du Ségur de 183 euros pour un
montant le 16 millions d'euros et je
vous rappelle que aujourd'hui les femmes
sont toujours payées 15% de moins en
moyenne que les hommes à poste
équivalent il est temps en 2022 de faire
un geste dans cette mission que l'on
examine pour combler ce retard je vous
remercie merci alors deux amendements
identiques le 509 monsieur Billac
donc normalement de Nathalie Delattre
donc depuis deux circulaires de mai
dernier les établissements et services
d'aide par le travail des esats
bénéficier d'une aide versée par nos
fonds d'accompagnement de la
transformation des établissements et
services d'aide par le travail fatesat
pour soutenir leur transformation en
2022 le montant de crédits dédié à ce
fond c'est levé à 15 millions d'euros
inscrit dans le cadre du plan de relance
hors ces crédits ne sont pas reconduits
en 2023 du fait de la fin du diplôme de
relance ainsi nous proposons d'augmenter
de 15 millions d'euros la dotation à
louer à l'action en location aide en
faveur des personnes handicapées du
programme handicap indépendance afin de
poursuivre la transformation entamée
dans de bonnes conditions pour les
travailleurs en ESAT
merci beaucoup le 541 madame le werrou
donc cet amendement visa maintenir les
crédits dédiés aux nouveaux fonds
d'accompagnement de la transformation
des établissements et services d'aide
par le travail fatesat suite au
circulaire du 11 et 13 mai 2022 les
établissements ESAT peuvent bénéficier
d'une adversée par le nouveau fond pour
soutenir leur transformation le montant
des crédits dédié au fait à 15 millions
d'euros dans le cadre du plan de relance
or le bleu budgétaire ne nous permet pas
de voir que ces crédits seront
reconduits pour 2023 deux questions se
posent celle du montant dévolu à la mise
en œuvre en 2023 des projets déjà
sélectionnés ainsi que la poursuite de
la réforme de la transformation des
esats afin de poursuivre la
transformation entamée dans de bonnes
conditions pour les travailleurs en ESAT
cet amendement vise donc à ce qu'une
enveloppe au moins équivalente à celle
de 2022 soit reconduite en 2023 il
s'agit d'une
à minima puisque avec 15 millions
d'euros le fatesate est censé couvrir
les 1500 isads du territoire national or
il ne représente
que 10 000 euros par structure ce qui ne
permettra pas de répondre aux besoins
merci
553 monsieur joli
madame le Président Madame le ministre
mes chers collègues le conseiller
économique et social et environnemental
rappelait dans un rapport récent acidulé
la place des jeunes dans les territoires
ruraux que malgré des résultats
supérieurs à la moyenne nationale au
baccalauréat la proportion des jeunes
qui poursuivaient des études supérieures
étaient deux fois moindres que les
jeunes vivants en milieu urbain
notamment à cause de l'intensation mais
également à cause d'éloignement des
centres d'enseignement supérieur en
outre le taux des jeunes de 18-24 ans ne
poursuivant ni étude ni formation et
était de 4 points plus élevés que la
moyenne nationale
ces constats appellent à ne plus
dissocier de développement des
territoires et l'accompagnement des
jeunes dans la préparation de leur
avenir et de l'avenir de ces territoires
il est aussi proposé une action nouvelle
qui est celle de généraliser au niveau
national expérimentation menée par
l'association bocal en région Centre
intitulé Les jeunes s'emmêlent et
financés grâce aux paysa au regard de ce
dispositif pardon consiste à la mise en
place d'un maillage fin de référent
jeune capable d'aller à rencontre des
jeunes et de les accompagner dans leur
projet universitaire entrepreneuriale
mais aussi associative de repérer ceux
qui sont en difficulté et qui seraient
pilotés en quelque sorte par des
structures neutres ou siègerai et
changerait divers acteurs de la société
locale chef d'entreprise même de
l'emploi etc il est proposé de mettre ce
dispositif de l'élargir à titre
expérimentale dans deux régions où se
trouve une population de jeunes inf à la
moyenne nationale et c'est les raisons
pour lesquelles il propose une enveloppe
de 13 millions d'euros je vous remercie
merci l'amendement 54 madame Lubin
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre le présentament demain a pour
objet de permettre l'accompagnement dès
2023 du développement de 10 résidences
de répit partagées à titre de mesures
nouvelles financé à hauteur de 10
millions d'euros soit un million d'euros
par structure de 60 places
médico-sociales d'hébergement
temporaires 30 places est en consacrées
à l'accueil des personnes en situation
de handicap et 30 à celles des des
personnes âgées en perte d'autonomie
accompagnée d'au moins d'au moins autant
d'aidants au titre de la branche
autonomie gérée par la CNSA une
résidence répit partagée propose
l'accueil temporaire à vocation
médico-sociales de la personne aider en
présence d'un ou plusieurs aidants
familiaux bénéficiant conjointement
d'une offre de tourisme et vacances
adaptée à leurs attentes et besoins
réciproques bien que la stratégie
nationale 2020 2022 agir pour les
aidants et faites ce dispositif une
priorité ça mesure 12 de renforcement et
diversification des solutions de répit
il est constaté l'absence de
développement réel de ces solutions
pourtant fortement attendu par
l'ensemble des parties prenantes dont au
premier chef les associations des dents
prenant acte de ce PLFSS 2023 le conseil
de la CNSA exprimé une même attente
alertant sur le manque de mesure en
direction des aidants et de leurs
proches et en particulier la possibilité
pour eux de bénéficier de solutions de
répit plus d'une dizaine de territoires
et au premier chef leur conseille
départementaux toujours en lien avec les
associations représentatives des
personnes et des aidants sont porteurs
de ces projets novateurs de résidence de
répit partagé dont le terme la ministre
qui vous est au moins aussi cher qu'à
moi celui des Landes aussi par cet
amendement nous vous proposons la
création au sein de la mission
solidarité insertion égalité des chances
d'un nouveau programme fond d'appui
territorial ou développement des
résidences de répit partagées composées
d'une action unique abondée des crédits
de l'action de 13 du programme 304
inclusion sociale et protection des
personnes à hauteur de 4 millions
d'euros en a eu en CP des crédits de
l'action le stress du programme sans ces
27.6 et nous vous demandons de lever le
gage merci chers collègues c'est parfait
amendement 509 même la présidente billon
en 2021 le gouvernement a lancé un plan
interministériel pour mieux lutter
contre la prostitution des mineurs qui
concernent entre 7 et 10000 jeunes en
France suite à un travail d'ailleurs
fouillé que la procureur chant Renault
avait mené et que nous avions auditionné
au sein de la délégation au droit des
femmes ce phénomène de prostitution de
mineur présent sur tout le territoire
touche surtout des jeunes filles
âgées de 15 à 17 ans avec un point
d'entrée dans la prostitution de plus en
plus tôt se situant entre 14 et 15 ans
pour plus de la moitié d'entre elles le
plan qui a été déployé sur les années
2021-2022 vise à sensibiliser et à
informer les mineurs à renforcer les
repérages des jeunes impliqués à
accompagner ceux en situation
prostitutionnelle ainsi qu'un renforcer
l'action judiciaire contre les clients
et les des actions doivent être
déployées au cours de l'année 2023
élèves hélas pardon le projet de loi de
finances ne prévoit pas de moyens
financiers fléchés spécifiquement sur la
lutte contre la prostitution des mineurs
les moyens financiers employés pour
l'année 2022 était
issu d'un report de crédit non consommé
en 2021 le plan ayant été tartifmenté le
poulaillé au cours de sa première année
cependant ces crédits doivent être
doivent à présent être renouvelés et
garanti pour 2023 comme je vous le
disais ce sont 7 atibils mineurs qui se
trouve en danger tant physiquement que
psychologiquement c'est pour cela que je
vous invite à voter cet amendement qui
vise à s'assurer que ce plan de lutte
contre la prostitution des mineurs dont
l'importance ne peut être ignorée et
bien dotée de crédits nécessaires à son
bon déploiement pour l'année à venir je
vous remercie merci l'amendement 550
madame le HOUEROU
alors on change de sujet puisqu'il
s'agit et pour avant d'y revenir
d'ailleurs c'est il s'agit d'une demande
de versement automatique du RSA pour
éviter la situation de non recours le
taux de non recours aux aides sociales
et minima sociaux et estimé à environ un
tiers des potentiels bénéficiaires c'est
autant de personnes en situation de
grande précarité qui ne peuvent disposer
de leur droit d'après Elena Réville
chercheuse à l'Université de Grenoble
c'est non recours sont expliqués par la
complexité du chemin pour demander des
aides c'est un parcours du combattant il
faut d'abord s'adresser aux caisses
assurances maladie constituer un dossier
puis se tourner vers des organismes
complémentaires et à chaque étape il y a
des incompréhensions qui font que le
dossier ne va pas au bout ainsi si nous
avons pu réaliser le prélèvement à la
source pour les impôts nous pensons
qu'il est nécessaire d'engager une
automatisation et de la réaliser pour le
versement du RSA
merci
l'amendement 711 madame gréaume
merci par cet amendement d'appel nous
proposons d'investir pour généraliser
les contrats jeunes majeurs au majeurs
qui sont passés par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance dont la plupart sont en très
grande difficulté les départements ont
réduit ces dernières années la durée le
montant des contrats jeune majeurs vu
les crédits insuffisants et les baisses
de dotation les départements ont besoin
de l'État pour les soutenir dans cette
action en effet environ 36% des ex de
l'ASEE bénéficient d'un contrat jeune
majeur de durée variable et montant
différents face à ces inégalités nous
estimons qui revient à l'état de
garantir un statut social pour tous les
jeunes majeurs de 18 à 21 ans et assurer
la généralisation des contrats jeunes
majeurs à l'ensemble des majeurs de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance tel est le
sens de cet amendement d'appel merci
merci l'amendement 712 madame a poursaut
poli merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement d'appel visent donc à étendre
le RSA aux jeunes de moins de 25 ans
d'après la dernière étude de
l'Observatoire des inégalités la moitié
des plus pauvres au moins de 30 ans le
taux de chômage atteint parmi nous eux
excusez moi les 20% selon le président
des Restos du cœur la moitié des
bénéficiaires à moins de 25 ans un
sentiment que partage la Fondation Abbé
Pierre et le Secours catholique mais
également les associations
étudiantes vivre avec 580 euros par mois
ce n'est pas un idéal pour personne et
ceci à n'importe quel âge il faudrait
évidemment aller plus loin avec un
véritable statut social pour l'ensemble
des jeunes lors de la pandémie de
covid-19 l'ancien premier ministre Jean
Castex occupé par la gestion des retards
de métro et de manque de conducteur de
bus avait refusé de mettre en œuvre
cette proposition une tribune publiée
dans le JDD demandant l'extension du R
pour les 18-25 ans avait pourtant été
signé par plusieurs associations dont la
Fondation Abbé Pierre les Apprentis
d'Auteuil la Fédération des associations
générales et l'Union nationale des
étudiants de France aujourd'hui il est
encore possible de ne pas sacrifier les
jeunes qui sont l'avenir de notre pays
aussi assurons leur un revenu minimum
pour lutter contre la précarité telle
est donc le sens de notre amendement je
vous remercie merci l'amendement 329 de
la commission des affaires sociales
présentées par monsieur le rapporteur
Jean-Sol madame le Président Madame les
ministres monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le groupement d'intérêt public
France en France protégé créé par les
lois du 7 février 2022 relative à la
protection des enfants résulte du gros
groupement du Gyps en France en danger
JPEG de l'Agence Française de l'Adoption
du Conseil national pour l'accès aux
origines personnelles et du Conseil
national de la protection de l'enfance
à compter du 1er janvier 2023 le nouveau
Jeep exercera au niveau national des
missions d'appui au pouvoir public dans
la mise en oeuvre de la politique
publique de protection de la de
l'enfance d'adoption nationale et
internationale et d'accès aux origines
personnelles il contribuera l'animation
à la coordination et à la cohérence des
pratiques sur l'ensemble du territoire
la loi prévoit que le Gyp est financer à
part égale par l'État et les
départements dans les conditions
définies par sa convention constitutive
répondant à une demande des départements
l'article 46 quaters du PLF inséré à
l'Assemblée nationale permet cependant à
titre dérogatoire que la part de l'État
dans ce financement soit supérieur à
celle des départements en 2023 toutefois
le coût supplémentaire qui devrait en
résulter pour l'État n'a pas été
répercuté dans les crédits de la mission
afin que le report de la montée en
charge de la contribution des
départements le compromettent pas la
capacité du Jeep à exercer ses missions
cet amendement de la commission des
affaires sociales vise à abonder de 1,4
millions d'euros les à leur financement
merci
endement
sociale à la sortie la prostitution à
hauteur du RSA en effet au premier rang
des violences faites aux femmes nous
comptons la prostitution depuis
l'adoption de la loi de
2016 les moyens financiers dégagés pour
faire vivre l'ambition abolitionniste de
la France ne sont pas au rendez-vous et
cela se ressent sur le terrain on
propose par cet amendement de faire
passer le montant de la fiche à hauteur
du RSA quoi de plus normal pour des
femmes déjà très fortement précarisés
dans mon département en Loire-Atlantique
l'accompagnement vers le parcours de
sortie de prostitution est assurée par
le mouvement le nid il emploie une
travailleuse sociale pour accompagner
les personnes en situation de
prostitution vers la sortie ce salaire
coûte 44000 euros par an et le nid
perçoit une subvention entre 20 et 22000
euros de l'État on voit vite
l'insuffisance de la la question pour
l'association qui s'interroge sur le
renouvellement de son agrément alors
même que les sorties de de parcours
enfin les parcours réussi de sortie de
prostitution sont nombreux les moyens
méritent d'être développés s'agissant du
montant de la fils pour les personnes en
situation de prostitution comme pour les
associations qui accompagnent les femmes
merci l'amendement 714 même coin oui cet
amendement d'appel vise à augmenter de
500.000 euros le financement des
associations qui accompagnent les
personnes sortant de la prostitution et
l'aide financière à l'insertion
professionnelle versée aux personnes
s'engageant dans un parcours de sortie
de la prostitution en effet la mission
solidarité prévoit une très légère
augmentation de l'enveloppe allouée à
l'aide financière pour l'insertion
sociale des signaux aux personnes en
parcours de sortie de prostitution de
plus 0,3%. alors que le nombre de
bénéficiaires à triplé entre 2018 et
2021 le montant de l'affiche qui est je
le rappelle de 363 euros reste très
faible et insuffisamment incitatif comme
le note le rapport spécial du Sénat de
nos collègues Arnaud Bazin et Eric
Bocquet notre amendement propose donc
d'augmenter les crédits destinés à la
prévention à la lutte contre les
violences et la prostitution de 500000
euros afin d'adresser un signal y
compris aux victimes de ce système
prostitutionnel qui est mortifère j'en
profite pour demander la pleine
application de la loi du 13 avril 2016
renforçant la lutte contre le système
prostitutionnel et la compagnement des
personnes prostituées afin de donner des
moyens à la hauteur des besoins aux
commissions départementales chargées de
mettre en place les parcours de sortie
de la prostitution la situation est
inacceptable au regard de l'enjeu
prioritaire que représente la lutte
contre la prostitution et la
marchandisation des corps quel est le
sens de cet amendement d'appel je vous
remercie merci
amendement 668 madame Vaugel merci
madame la Présidente l'aide à la vie
familiale et sociale des anciens
migrants dans leur pays d'origine
constitue financière destiné à
accompagner le rapprochement familial
des travailleurs migrants âgés et plus
spécifiquement de la population des
Chibani qui partagent leur vie entre le
pays d'origine et des foyers de
travailleurs migrants ou résidences
sociales en France ce dispositif permet
de sécuriser leurs droits sociaux de ce
qu'ils effectuent des séjours de longue
durée dans leur pays d'origine plus de 6
mois c'est à dire de continuer à
percevoir une prestation comparable au
minimum vieillesse ce qui est impossible
avec l'ASPA qui elle suppose de résider
en France
sous prétexte que le recours à cette
aide est en baisse le gouvernement fait
dans ce budget le choix de baisser les
crédits à louer pour notre part nous
considérons au contraire qu'il est
nécessaire de maintenir les moyens
budgétaires à louer l'an dernier et
invitons le gouvernement à plutôt lutter
contre les non recours évidemment
l'objectif n'est pas de réduire le
budget de l'action 17 du programme 124
c'est simplement pour respecter
l'article 40 de la Constitution que nous
avons construit la maman comme ça et
l'objectif c'est bien d'alerter le
gouvernement sur le besoin de maintenir
les crédits dont il est question
identique à se voter en 2022 je vous
merci la maman 542 madame le beau
Hérault
il concerne donc également les le budget
pour accompagner les femmes victimes de
violence dans son rapport de 2020
intitulé où est l'argent pour mieux
protéger les femmes victimes de violence
examinant donc les moyens dont dispose
la politique publique afférente la
Fondation des femmes proposent la
création d'un observatoire national des
féminicides cet amendement ajoute donc
au budget consacré à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes 500.000 euros dans
le but de créer cette observatoire et de
lui permettre de fonctionner
immédiatement la mise en application de
cette proposition nous paraît
indispensable d'abord parce que
aujourd'hui le décompte des meurtres
conjugaux réalisés et réalisé par le
collectif féminicide par compagnon ou ex
qui a permis de mettre en lumière la
réalité dramatique et implacable des
féminicides commis sur notre territoire
cette mise en lumière a participé à une
mobilisation exceptionnelle de la
société en matière de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes et toujours
des familles de victimes ensuite comme
l'ont révélé les investigations du monde
une part significative des féminicides
aurait pu être évité
en troisième lieu donc il s'agit
également de prévoir une structure
capable de répertorier mais également
d'analyser les meurtres des femmes en
raison de leur sexe
en raison de leur secteur permet de
répondre partiellement aux conséquences
de la disparition de l'Observatoire
national de la délinquance et des
réponses pénales l'année dernière
ensuite nous devons également à la
mémoire de trop nombreuses victimes
l'engagement ferme et entier de toute la
société dans un seul but éradiquer les
violences faites aux femmes la
proposition est donc de créer cette
observatoire et qui s'insère pleinement
dans les une réponse donc aux objectifs
que je viens de citer merci l'amendement
500 même de Marco
[Musique]
pour conclure mes chers collègues lutter
contre la précarité de notre jeunesse ce
n'est pas de l'assistanat c'est investir
pour l'avenir
merci l'amendement 573 madame ponce
merci
la Présidente c'est un moment d'appel se
propose de déployer des moyens afin
d'améliorer le recours à la
complémentaire santé solidaire un
article de l'Institut de recherche et de
documentation en économie de la santé
mais 2022 indique à partir de l'enquête
Santé européenne de 2019 que 2,5
millions de Français demeurent sans
complémentaires santé les personnes les
plus pauvres sont toujours les plus
concernées par l'absence de
complémentaires santé selon l'article
précité la situation économique et
sociale des individus reste le principal
déterminant de la souscription d'une
complémentaire santé et surtout du
niveau de garantie souscrit les familles
monoparentales les personnes en dehors
du marché de l'emploi les retraités les
plus pauvres sont particulièrement
impactés parmi les causes de l'absence
de complémentaires santé on compte un
tiers de non recours au droit de la CSS
notamment en raison de difficultés
administratives
la CSS sont mutualisant les anciens
dispositifs de la CMU C et de la CS
avaient pourtant pour objectif premier
de faciliter l'accès des bénéficiaires
potentiels cet amendement se propose
d'accentuer les efforts déployés afin de
lutter contre le non recours à la
complémentaire santé solidaire dans une
logique de prévention et d'aller vers
les populations les plus fragilisées à
titre d'exemple programme que c'est
amendement vis a créé pourrait permettre
d'automatiser l'affiliation à la C2S et
de financer de vastes opérations de
phoning auprès des personnes éligibles
il s'agit ici d'un amendement d'appel
d'une somme d'un euro symbolique mais
qui permet de créer une mission dédiée à
lutter enfin contre le non recours à la
complémentaire santé solidaire
merci l'amendement 574 m'a impensé mon
ma présidente donc par cet amendement
d'appel nous demandons la mise en place
d'un véritable plan d'éradication du
sens-abrisme qui était d'ailleurs une
promesse
du de Monsieur Macron
dès la première année de son mandat le
rapport annuel de la Fondation Abbé
Pierre sur l'état du mal logement en
2022 indique que le nombre de cent
domicile fixes s'élèverait au moins en
France à 300.000 personnes d'après un
rapport d'information fait au nom de la
commission des finances du signe du
Sénat sur la politique d'hébergement
d'urgence la crise sanitaire a accentué
les limites déjà existantes de la
politique d'hébergement l'année 2020
ayant mobilisé le secteur de
l'hébergement d'urgence à un niveau
inédit s'il n'y a aucun chiffre officiel
sur le nombre de sans-papiers parmi les
structures d'hébergement d'urgence
plusieurs acteurs du secteur estiment
qu'il constitue un public majoritaire
afin de combattre l'embolie du système
d'hébergement d'urgence le directeur de
l'Office français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration Didier Le
défendent défend le fait de faciliter la
régularisation des familles qui stagnent
depuis de nombreuses années dans
l'hébergement d'urgence si une forte
mobilisation des élus locaux a permis de
convaincre le gouvernement de renoncer à
la fermeture de 14000 places d'ici
l'année prochaine permettant de ce fait
de stabiliser le parc des bergesment à
hauteur de 197000 places cela n'est pas
suffisant cet amendement nécessiterait
l'abondement de sommes considérables
pour un programme dédié aux sans-abrisme
et conviendrait non seulement de créer
des places d'hébergement mais aussi et
surtout de libérer des places par des
sorties plus rapides vers le logement
donc cet amendement invite à amorcer un
plan plus réanuel de grande ampleur
merci là maintenant 667 m'a impensé
mangent
alors cet amendement est un amendement
d'appel pour demander au gouvernement de
publier le rapport sur le revenu
universel d'activité je voudrais d'abord
rappeler la jeunesse de ce rapport fin
2018 Emmanuel Macron lançait en grande
pompe la stratégie de prévention et de
lutte contre la pauvreté depuis la
stratégie c'est réduit à la principale
mesure qui a consisté à distribuer des
petits déjeuners à l'école c'est
important les petits déjeuners à l'école
je n'en dis ce qu'on vient pas mais ça
ne radique pas la pauvreté pour les
enfants je rappelle un enfant sur cinq
vit sous le seuil de pauvreté en France
alors en 2019 le président annonçait la
fusion des minima sociaux on a revenu
universel d'activités un projet acquis
selon l'exécutif devait répondre aux
problèmes de la pauvreté mais qui n'a à
ce stade toujours pas abouti et n'a en
réalité que braquer contre lui les
principaux acteurs de lutte contre
l'exclusion face à ce projet constatons
son incapacité à formuler des réponses
subtiles et partagées pour lutter contre
la pauvreté et l'exclusion la dernière
initiative du gouvernement fut de
missionné l'adresse pour rédiger un
rapport sur le revenu universel
d'activité qui bien que remis en main
propre au Premier ministre de l'époque
n'a jamais été rendu public par le
gouvernement franchement qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui peut justifier que sur une
question si fondamentale pour
l'organisation sociale de notre société
un rapport remis au Premier ministre
soit gardé confidentiels y compris pour
le Parlement attaché au débat et à la
confrontation des idées nous demandons
simplement qu'il soit publié la haute
administration a produit un travail je
ne sais pas ce qu'il y a dedans mais je
sais que c'est qu'on en soit d'accord ou
non avec le projet que l'on partage ou
non le contenu du rapport lui-même il en
va de la transparence et de la bonne
santé démocratique que les rapports
demandés en plus remis soient publié
soit publié pour éclairer les décideurs
les décideurs publics et par excellence
le Parlement
merci David la commission monsieur le
rapporteurs présentaient les avis donc
avec votre permission de la Président je
donnerai la vie sur les trois premiers
422 puis 423 et 24 qui sont des
abonnements de replis portant sur le
même objet merci Madame alors le 422 qui
porte sur la politique d'accompagnement
du deuil le présentement vise à ouvrir
un montant de 522 millions d'euros pour
la politique d'accompagnement du deuil
bien qu'il s'agisse d'un problème grave
bien évidemment cette politique publique
ne s'inscrit que difficilement dans le
champ de la mission et des
administrations chargées de la mise en
oeuvre de ces différents programmes elle
nous semble davantage relevé de
l'Assurance Maladie voilà pour le 422 le
423 donc même objet mais cette fois-ci
le montant est proposé à 160 millions
d'euros et le 424 lui sur un montant de
200 millions d'euros donc demande de
retrait sur ces trois amendements
merci
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames les
ministres monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je prends maintenant le 534
qui vise à renforcer 250 millions
d'euros les crédits de la stratégie
pauvreté la baisse constatée en 2023 est
souligné par les auteurs de l'amendement
qui ont fait qu'en 2023 c'est une année
de transition avec la fin des contrats
départements dans l'attente de la
conclusion d'une nouvelle génération de
contrat nous avions critiqué dans nos
travaux de contrôle cette forme d'in
préparation et la nécessité de proroger
par deux fois les contrats en cours il
aurait été préférable d'anticiper
davantage pour lancer le nouvel
génération des cette année pour le reste
cet amendement dont la finalité n'est
pas précise en dehors du constat d'un
manque de moyens doit selon nous être
considéré comme un amendement d'appel
c'est pourquoi nous en demandons le
retrait
je prends ensuite
le
qui vise à renforcer de 125 millions
d'euros les crédits de la stratégie
pauvreté bon même chose c'est nos yeux
un amendement d'appel avec une demande
de retrait
sur le 535 avec la création d'un fonds
de prévention de l'inceste de 100
millions d'euros
nous observons que la prévention de
l'inceste est d'ores et déjà dans un des
axes de la stratégie de la protection de
l'enfance dont les crédits ont déjà
progressé de 70 millions d'euros au PLF
2023 c'est donc aussi une demande de
retrait
le 538 créations d'une cellule nationale
de conseils et de soutien pour les
professionnels destinataires de
révélation de violences sexuelles de la
part d'enfants et de tes 10 millions
d'euros en première lecture c'est
crédits ont des crédits ont déjà été
ajoutés pour permettre un tel soutien à
hauteur d'un million et demi d'euros
nous proposons de d'attendre pour voir
si des moyens supplémentaires sont
vraiment nécessaires pour les renforcer
le cas échéant l'an prochain c'est
également une demande de retrait sur le
vise le fond le financement d'un fonds
de repérage systématique des violences
sexuelles auprès de tous les enfants par
tous les professionnels et qui seraient
dotés de 5 millions d'euros cette lutte
contre les violences sexuelles je viens
de le rappeler fait déjà l'objet d'un
des axes stratégiques de protection de
l'enfance donc des crédits ont progressé
70 millions d'euros c'est également une
demande de retrait
merci
c'est un moment identique alors sur le
385 c'est bien ça
416 des 658 qui sont identiques alors
pour le 385 de notre collègue chassaint
donc le présent d'amendement visa
renforcé de 95 millions d'euros les
moyens de la politique de protection
juridique des majeurs certes le PLF
intègre la budgétisation à hauteur de 40
millions d'euros en année pleine d'une
revalorisation des mandataires dans le
cadre du Ségur et les crédits de cette
action atteignent 800 millions d'euros
plus 70 millions les auteurs de
l'amendement font valoir que le nombre
de mandataires est insuffisant pour
permettre une prise en charge des
mesures de protection dont la dynamique
est très importante dans des conditions
satisfaisantes ce constat est corroboré
par les auditions que nous avons pu
conduire lors de nos travaux c'est ces
dernières années nous souhaitons ainsi
demander l'avis du gouvernement afin de
savoir quels moyens pour être dégagé
pour remédier à ce problème structurel
merci
le 548
dans les je suis un peu perdu dans les
papiers voilà j'y suis
voilà le présent d'un moment visa
renforcé donc de 95 millions d'euros les
moyens de la politique de protection
juridique des majeurs certes le PLF
intègre voilà à la hauteur de 40
millions d'euros en année pleine tout
cela a déjà été dit donc là aussi nous
demandons l'avis du gouvernement pour
connaître les moyens décider pour
remédier à ce problème structurel
voilà idem pour le 60 même demande et
donc avis du gouvernement sur
l'amendement 60 présenté par notre
collègue mouillé
le 537 visa ouvrir 20 millions d'euros
pour le financement d'un fonds de
soutien pour les initiatives de
solidarité alimentaire territorialisées
l'amendement est satisfait puisque le
projet doit être finance prévoit déjà 60
millions d'euros supplémentaires pour
financer un nouveau fond pour les
nouvelles solidarités alimentaires dont
la gestion serait déconcentrée nous
considérons comme notre part et j'ai eu
l'occasion de le directeur à la tribune
qui serait préférable d'utiliser ces
crédits nouveaux pour financer
directement les associations qui sont
considérablement fragilisés par la crise
énergétique et par la problématique de
l'eau infructueux et également de
l'inflation sur tous les produits
alimentaires certes prévoir de la
qualité des circuits courts peut-être un
chèque alimentaire tout ça pourrait être
débattu mais aujourd'hui l'urgence de
l'urgence c'est que les associations
puissent continuer à tourner dans le
modèle français associatif et c'est ce à
quoi nous vous engageons donc ce sera
une demande de retrait sur le 549 et
c'est un amendement d'appel qui vise à
revaloriser les personnels du programme
137 celui-ci ne finançant pas de
dépenses de personnel il vise en réalité
les opérateurs financés par le programme
s'agissant de revalorisation salariale
de structure associatifs privées qui ne
sont donc pas décidées par l'État ils ne
semblent pas qu'une augmentation des
crédits soit opérante faudrait au sein
des associations pour en appliquer la
revalorisation qu'aux titres de la
compresse l'accomplissement des missions
conventionnelles avec l'État ce qui
pourrait être source de complexité voire
d'iniquité entre salariés et combien
également de noter qu'un tel amendement
représenterait à lui seul près de la
moitié des crédits du programme qui ont
déjà connu une progression importante
ces dernières années 15% de plus en PLF
2023 c'est donc une demande de retrait
mais mon collègue à titre personnel lui
est fort
le 594
revalorisation de 16 millions d'euros
pour les métiers financés par le
programme égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et identiques
de retrait pour la commission des
finances on a ensuite encore un
identique me semble-t-il avec le 710
le 710 demande de retrait de par la
commission des finances et le 509
voilà pour le 509 donc c'est un moment
prévoit de reconduire les financements
octroyés pour la modernisation des
établissements et services d'aide par le
travail les ESAT dans le cadre du plan
de relance du fait de la fin du plan de
relance il n'existe en effet plus de
crédit dédié dans le présent PLF
toutefois la mise en œuvre des projets
retenus se poursuivra en revanche en
2023 c'est amendement est l'occasion
d'interroger le gouvernement sur le
bilan du fatesat l'opportunité de
reconduire un tel fond en 2023 comme
cela a été prévu sur la mission travail
et emploi s'agissant du fonds de
transformation des entreprises adaptées
nous demandons donc la vie du
gouvernement sur cet amendement 509
ensuite
on a le 553 qui est un peu différent
donc déploiement de référent jeunesse en
zone rurale c'est un moment propose de
financer le déploiement titre
expérimental durant 5 ans dans deux
régions où la part des jeunes est moins
importante au sein de la population
totale du département de procéder au
déploiement de référents jeunesse si
l'idée est intéressante elle fait écho à
d'autres dispositifs financés par la
Mission enseignement scolaire notamment
les cordées de la réussite en outre les
référents jeunesse restent à définir
l'amendement nous semble donc relever
d'un appel au ministre qui pourra
développer sur les politiques déjà en
cours donc c'est une demande de retrait
merci
554 54 vise le financement d'un fond
d'appui territorial au développement de
résidence de répit partagé pour 12
millions d'euros destinés au
développement territorial de solutions
temporaires de répit partagé entre les
aidants et leurs proches en situation de
handicap maladie chronique ou perte
d'autonomie liée à l'âge il nous semble
que l'État doit participer aux côtés des
départements un soutien renforcé aux
aidants dont l'appui est essentielle et
précieux et qui sont trop souvent
laissés pour compte c'est donc un avis
favorable de la commission des finances
sur le 599
qui prévoit de renforcer à hauteur de 7
millions d'euros les moyens du plan
interministériel doté de 14 millions
d'euros pour lutter contre la
prostitution des mineurs les moyens de
ce plan nous paraissent relevés
davantage de la direction de prothèse de
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
et donc du ministère de la Justice
plutôt que de la mission que nous
examinons néanmoins cet amendement est
l'occasion d'int que le gouvernement
pour faire le point sur la mise en
oeuvre du plan son éventuel articulation
avec la stratégie protection de
l'enfance en partie portée par la
mission elle et sur la nécessité de
renforcer ses moyens je sollicite donc
la vie du gouvernement
le 550 qui porte sur le versement
automatique du RSA mais qui est doté de
5 millions d'euros est à nos yeux un
amendement d'appel qui est l'occasion
d'interroger le gouvernement sur la
traduction concrète de la promesse de
solidarité à la source mais sinon c'est
une demande de retrait
merci
71 le présente un moment propose
d'ouvrir 5 millions d'euros au titre de
la généralisation du dispositif de
Contrat Jeune majeurs visant à
accompagner les jeunes sortant de l'azo
il nous semble que ce type de dispositif
en lien avec les compétences
départementales doit faire l'objet d'une
approche différenciée selon les
territoires plutôt que la dispositif
uniforme piloté par l'État la prévention
des sorties sèches de l'ASEE a constitué
l'un des principaux axes des contrats
états départements dans le cadre de la
stratégie pauvreté et doivent le rester
pour la prochaine génération de contrats
donc c'est une demande de retrait pour
la Commission à titre personnel
favorable sur les 712 c'est amendement
visa ouvrir le débat sur l'extension du
RSA aux personnes âgées de moins de 25
ans au vu du montant demandé 5 millions
d'euros il ne peut s'agir que d'un
amendement d'appel telle mesure réelle
avant tout écart en toute état de cause
pardon de la loi demande de retrait sauf
à titre personnel c'est la schizophrénie
et le 329 présenté par notre collègue
sole c'est un rendement visa relevé de
1,4 millions euros la contribution de
l'État au financement du nouveau gypse
en France protégée en effet comme le
semis ne rapporteur pour avis les
conséquences budgétaires de l'article 46
souhaitaient insérés dans le texte
considéré comme adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale n'ont pas été tirés sur les
crédits de la mission premier mémoire
cet article permet de déroger au
principe de financement paritaire entre
l'État et les départements en 2023 d'où
il résulte nécessairement un relèvement
de la contribution de l'État ce sera un
avis favorable
543 visa relever les crédits de la fiche
de 1,3 millions d'euros en effet le
montant de la fille c'est de 343 euros
mensuels contre 598,50 € pour le RSA le
montant de la fiche nous paraît donc
insuffisant pour vivre décemment comme
la souligner d'ailleurs récemment un
rapport de ligace cité par les auteurs
il incite les auteurs à accepter des
emplois très peu qualifiés pour trouver
un complément de revenu au détriment du
succès de leur parcours de formation la
lutte contre la prostitution étant un
enjeu de public de politique publique
majeure son portage est insuffisant il
faut renforcer le montant de la fiche
c'est aussi contribuer à inciter
davantage de victimes à s'orienter vers
un parcours de sortie de prostitution
nous voyons pas pourquoi l'État ne
compte consacrerait pas pour le
financement des prestations dont il a la
charge un effort au moins similaire à
celui qui l'impose au département pour
les personnes en voie d'insertion pour
toutes ces raisons nous donnant un avis
favorable à cet amendement
le 714 c'est aussi un amendement qui
porte sur les moyens de lutte contre la
prostitution avec un budget renforcé de
500 000 euros comme c'est un amendement
d'appel c'est l'occasion d'ouvrir le
débat c'est une demande de retrait le
668 augmentation des crédits destinés
aux financement de l'aide à la vie
familiale et sociale des anciens
migrants dans les pays d'origine
l'avaits pardon il nous semble que c'est
un amendement n'est pas opérant car la
VFS est un droit ouvert dont les
conditions d'attribution sont
déterminées par l'article l117,3 du code
de l'action sociale et des familles le
montant inscrit au présent PLF n'est
donc qu'une prévision c'est donc une
demande de retrait
merci
542 sur l'amendement 542 le présent de
maman vise à ouvrir 500 000 euros de
crédit supplémentaire pour le
financement d'un observatoire national
des féminicides si la cause est le
premier importance la mission
interministérielle pour la protection
des femmes le mi-prof du ministère de
l'Intérieur publie déjà des études sur
le sujet ainsi on sait qu'en 2021 122
femmes ont été tuées par leur
ex-compagnon au compagnon et nous paraît
pas donc utile et efficace de multiplier
les structures l'amendement nous semble
satisfait demande de retrait pour le 500
c'est amendement visé ouvrir le débat
sur l'extension du RSA aux personnes
âgées de moins de 25 ans au vu du
montant demandé donc 1 euro il ne peut
s'agir que d'un amendement d'appel une
telle mesure relève en toute état de
cause de la loi donc demande de retrait
favorable à titre personnel et pour le
573 amendement qui vise à ouvrir le
débat sur le non recours à la
complémentaire santé solidaire aux
personnes âgées de moins de 25 ans là
aussi au vu de montant demandé un euro
il ne peut se dire que d'un amendement
d'appel une telle mesure re dans tous
les tas de cause avantages du PLFSS
selon nous demande de retrait merci
574 oui c'est un amendement qui voudrait
obtenir l'éradication du sans-abrisme
mais il est inscrit à montant d'un euro
il s'agit là aussi d'un amendement
d'appel une telle mesure relève en tout
état de cause avantage de la politique
du logement que de la mission ou de la
mission cohésion des territoires que de
notre mission c'est donc une demande de
retrait
de 667 demande une publication d'un
rapport sur le revenu universel
d'activité donc il vise manifestement à
ouvrir le débat sur cette question vu le
montant inscrit également c'est un
amendement d'appel mais le projet de Rua
semble avoir été abandonné au profit du
projet de solidarité à la source donc je
renouvelle le questionnement au
Gouvernement sur ce sujet
merci beaucoup alors la vie du
gouvernement je ne sais pas qui prend la
parole en premier monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs donc on va se
succéder pour répondre pour donner la
vie du gouvernement sur les différents
amendements alors je vais essayer d'être
le plus clair possible je vais répondre
immédiatement pour les amendements 422
423 424 sur la question de
l'accompagnement du deuil qui est
évidemment un sujet de préoccupation
pour le gouvernement qui
œuvre constamment à améliorer cet
accompagnement c'est notamment pour
c'est notamment pour cela que nous avons
mis en place un congé pour deuil
parental pour accompagner la douleur des
parents qui vivent le drame de la perte
d'un enfant par ailleurs
l'accompagnement des personnes
endeuillées doit être fait bien en amont
du décès et c'est pour cela que
l'accompagnement des aidants des
personnes en fin de vie est un axe
important du plan en cours de
développement des soins palliatifs et de
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie et en
second lieu concernant les
professionnels confrontés à
l'accompagnement des personnes en deuil
différentes formations
il existe déjà dans le cadre de la
formation continue donc contenu ces
événements nous suivons la vie de la des
rapporteurs à vie négatifs concernant
l'amendement numéro 533
donc qui concerne la stratégie de
prévention et de lutte
53 vous avez fait 422 423 424 530 vous
voulez qu'on fasse dans l'ordre parce
que je pour nous ça va être compliqué
quand même
essayer au maximum de faire dans l'ordre
sauf si sauf si c'est sauf si c'est une
de vos collègues qui qui défend
à ce moment là c'est pas gênant
vous pouvez faire tous vos amendements à
vous la condition de les prendre tous
dans l'ordre comme ça et puis donc la
ministre prendra
concernant le 533 sur l'abondement des
crédits la stratégie nationale de
prévention et de lutte contre la
pauvreté la première ministre l'a
annoncé le 3 novembre dernier à cette
stratégie lutte contre la pauvreté va
succéder à
un impact national des solidarités qui
va s'appuyer sur le
la stratégie précédente et son
évaluation il comportera quatre axes et
deux premiers sont ceux qui étaient qui
ont bien fonctionné dans la stratégie
précédente à savoir la lutte contre les
inégalités de destin et la reproduction
sociale de la pauvreté le second c'est
l'insertion par l'emploi le troisième
qui me tient particulièrement à coeur et
vous le comprendrez c'est celui contre
la de la lutte contre la grande
conclusion et enfin de faire de cette
transition écologique une transition
solidaire et donc de travailler en
profondeur sur la question de la
réduction pour les foyers modestes des
charges contraintes que représente
l'alimentation l'axe à l'alimentation
l'hébergement et la mobilité
en attendant la mise en place de ce
pacte des solidarité qui interviendra à
partir de 2024 et donc nous
recontactualiserons avec les
collectivités en 2023 l'année 2023 sera
donc une année de transition c'est pour
cela que facilement les crédits les
crédits baisse puisqu'en fait l'idée
c'est de remettre en cohérence les
calendriers des différentes
contractualisations certaines
collectivités devront donc
contractualiser en 2023 pour six mois
pour accompagner ces départements donc
dont les crédits vont baisser sur
l'année 2023 on a mis en place une
enveloppe complémentaire notamment pour
renforcer les crédits à l'insertion et
au total c'est contrat de lutte contre
la pauvreté représenteront 94% de ceux
effectivement contractualisé en 2021
donc la baisse n'est pas celle que vous
mentionnez donc pour ces raisons je suis
défavorable à votre amendement
concernant les amendements
385 416 et 658 et donc l'augmentation
des crédits de la protection juridique
des majeurs je pense qu'on poursuit avec
ce projet de loi de finance pour 2023 le
même objectif celui d'améliorer la
qualité de la prise en charge des
personnes protégées l'un des moyens en
effet consiste à diminuer le nombre de
personnes prises en charge par
mandataire judiciaire c'est la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement a augmenté
le budget de 7,1 million d'euros pour
2023 afin notamment de prévoir
l'embauche de 200 mandataires
supplémentaires cette mesure a un
caractère progressif compte tenu des
délais nécessaires pour la formation et
le recrutement de ces nouveaux
mandataires des métiers qui ne font pas
exception dans le champ dont j'ai la
responsabilité en termes d'attractivité
c'est en 2023 qu'elle connaîtra donc son
plein effet il nous semble indispensable
d'évaluer l'effet des nouveaux
recrutements avant vous allez plus loin
par ailleurs les métiers du secteur
social au sens large connaissent une
véritable crise d'attractivité je viens
de le dire qui ne n'épargne pas la
protection juridique et nous sommes
nécessaires d'aborder cette question de
façon plus globale plusieurs travaux en
cours doivent permettre de structurer en
profondeur le secteur de la protection
judiciaire des majeurs avec en
particulier la refonte de la formation
initiale des mandataires avec
l'instauration d'une filière dédiée
universelle universitarisé autour d'une
licence professionnelle mais également
l'intégration de la protection
judiciaire des majeurs dans la politique
d'accompagnement global des personnes
vulnérables pour toutes ces raisons nous
donnons un avis défavorable à l'ensemble
de ces amendements
concernant ensuite
juste monsieur je rappelle que nous
sommes dans un temps contraint et que si
vous voulez revenir samedi ou dimanche
moi je suis prévue pour présider
dimanche soir donc pas de souci
il faut peut-être juste un tout petit
peu raccourcir voilà les explications
peut-être pas favorable et favorable ça
a besoin quand même de réponse mais
peut-être quelque chose d'un peu plus
court merci
je vais donc accélérer
537 sur le fond de soutien aux
initiatives de solidarité de citoyenneté
alimentaire les rapporteurs l'ont dit on
a mis en place dès la première ministre
l'a annoncé un fond de 60 millions
d'euros dédiés dédiés à cette question
donc votre amendement est satisfait vous
m'interrogez sur la façon dont nous
allons dépenser cet argent préalablement
je rappelle que les crédits au total
pour l'aide alimentaire pour 2022 ont
été triplés entre les deux projets de
loi de finances rectificatives 55
millions d'euros cet été 40 millions
d'euros supplémentaires avec le dernier
projet de loi de finances rectificative
qui permettent de soutenir directement
les réseaux d'aide alimentaire donc les
grandes associations et donc leur
permettre de faire face au contrainte
liées à l'inflation problématique
d'approvisionnement et de crise
énergétique qui bénéficie d'ailleurs par
ailleurs des des dispositifs qui ont été
mis en place pour faire grâce à cette
crise de l'énergie donc à vie
défavorable du gouvernement sur cette
question concernant l'amendement 554 qui
concerne le fond d'appui territorial au
développement des résidences de respires
partagés
vous dire que évidemment le répit est un
sujet de forte préoccupation pour le
gouvernement qui l'avait d'ailleurs
inscrit dans la précédente stratégie
nationale agir pour les aidants 2020
dans cette dans cette stratégie donc on
avait un cadre pour le pour développer
l'offre de répit et d'accueil temporaire
on a par ailleurs missionné l'IGAS pour
évaluer cette cette stratégie et la
question de la solution
des solutions pardon de répit donc nous
attendons les conclusions de la mission
de Liga je suis désolé c'est difficile
de répondre de façon rapide et donc pour
ces raisons nous vous proposons de
rejeter cet amendement
l'amendement 550 concernant le versement
automatique du RSA là aussi nous
partageons vos préoccupations c'est
l'objectif du chantier de solidarité à
la source que j'ai engagé qui va viser à
s'appuyer sur les informations dont
disposés différentes administrations sur
les situations des personnes pour
s'adresser à elle et donc d'aller vers
les potentiels bénéficiaires du RSA
nous commencerons dès 2023 avec une
expérimentation territoire zéro non
recours qui avait été prévu dans la loi
3DS et qui permettra d'expérimenter
cette lutte contre le non recours dans
une dizaine de département
concernant maintenant j'ai mélangé des
trucs le 712 sur les crédits
supplémentaires pour étendre le RSA au
moins de 25 ans vous ça ne vous étonnera
pas que le gouvernement aimé un avis
défavorable à ce sujet puisque
un certain nombre de dispositifs
existent déjà pour les moins de 25 de
moins de 25 ans pardon ils ont accès
notamment à la prime d'activité ils
peuvent bénéficier de l'accompagnement
vers l'emploi du plan un jeune une
solution et depuis le début de l'année
2022 ils ont accès au contrat
d'engagement jeune le gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé pour venir en
soutien à la jeunesse néanmoins nous
pensons que il faut que nous fassions en
créant les conditions d'une meilleure
insertion sociale et professionnelle
d'où l'ensemble de ces dispositifs et
d'où le travail que nous faisons
actuellement dans le cadre de la réforme
France travail donc assez favorable sur
cette amendement sur le 668 donc la
question du maintien des crédits dans la
lutte contre le non recours à l'aide à
la vie familiale et sociale
si le montant qui figure dans le projet
de loi de finance et le résultat d'une
projection il n'est en aucun cas
limitatif donc toutes les personnes qui
peuvent légitimement bénéficier de sa
tête n'auront aucune difficulté à la
percevoir en 2023 donc le Gouvernement
est défavorable à cette amendement
concernant
mon numéro
je vais dire une bêtise
on en est où là
673 donc avis pardon 573 pardon avis
défavorable à cette amendement vous
souhaitez augmenter donc les moyens
mobilisés pour lutter contre le non
recours à la complémentaire santé
solidaire
toutes ces démarches de lutte contre non
recours feront partie là aussi des
travaux solidarités à la source et lutte
contre le non recours de façon de façon
générale on a mis en place un certain
nombre de mesures notamment d'aller vers
pour en direction des populations les
plus fragiles pour les aider à
bénéficier de cette de cette aide
sur le
574 création d'un nouveau programme dans
le but de supprimer la situation des
sans-abris voilà je mets ma vie que la
Commission
cet amendement relève plus de la mission
cohésion des territoires donc qui porte
les crédits dédiés au logement et à
l'hébergement d'urgence donc nous
rejetons cet amendement et enfin le 667
sur la création d'un nouveau programme
portant sur la publication du rapport
sur le revenu universel d'activité je
lui ai dit nous sommes engagés dans le
projet de solidarité à la source portée
par le Président de la République qui a
une réforme ambitieuse et qui va bien
au-delà du revenu universel d'activité
c'est pour cela qu'on n'a pas repris
effectivement les conclusions du rapport
Langlard on a néanmoins demandé à
l'adresse de travailler à de nouvelles
projections dans le cadre du projet de
solidarité à la source et donc pour ces
raisons nous sommes défavorables dans
votre abonnement
les amendements sur les le fait
parce que moi j'aurais voulu que ce soit
quand même ordre donc c'est à dire que
la ministre qui démarre et celle qui a
l'amendement 534 ça va être plus logique
merci donc
globalement ce je tiens rappeler que en
matière d'enfance comme je l'ai dit je
n'ai pas le monopole de toutes les
lignes budgétaires puisque mon collègue
ma collègue sur le handicap mon collègue
sur la pauvreté l'école la justice
l'aide alimentaire tout le monde
contribue au bien-être de nos enfants
sur la protection de l'enfance comme je
l'ai expliqué cette année est une année
de transition j'ai obtenu le maintien de
la fin je vous propose le maintien de la
contractualisation à hauteur de 140
millions d'euros auxquels s'ajoute 50
millions dédiés aux jeunes majeurs on
avait déjà eu 50 millions sur le budget
2022 on propose de maintenir 50 millions
sur le budget 2023 étant entendu
qu'aujourd'hui les départements ont des
difficultés à évaluer leurs besoins et
qu'on pourra toujours rectifier le cas
échéant si ses besoins venaient à
augmenter ce qui est important pour moi
c'est d'AM la gouvernance la gouvernance
nationale j'y reviendrai avec le Gyp
mais aussi la gouvernance territoriale
dans le cadre des conseils
départementaux de protection de
l'enfance où nous travaillerons cette
question de contractualisation avec des
objectifs extrêmement précis nous
évaluerons ce qui a été fait en 2022
2021 pour pouvoir améliorer nos demandes
pour le budget 204 s'agissant donc
l'objectif c'est donc d'une efficacité
des dépenses s'agissant du gypcom il a
été dit il sera créé au 1er janvier de
2023 le financement à parité connaît une
exception sur cette année de transition
nous considérons qu'aujourd'hui que le
programme 304 est calibré pour financer
les mesures nouvelles qui sont
relativement limitées il sera ajusté
éventuellement si nécessaire nous
n'avons pas encore commencé à
dépenser évidemment mais surtout il nous
faut laisser un peu de temps à ce Gy
pour voir s'il arrive à mettre en oeuvre
toutes ces mesures nouvelles
s'agissant des préconisations de la
civisme je tiens à dire que il ne faut
pas oublier que non seulement il y a le
programme de 304 mais bien sûr l'ONDAM
et le fear contribue largement à la
politique de prévention et de lutte
contre les victimes et de prise en
charge des victimes de violence
sexuelles sur les yeux à peine nous
avons quand même un au total 16 millions
d'euros qui sont donnés enfin qui sont
prévus entre les deux budgets firont
dames et le budget qui vous est présenté
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui 7,4 millions
d'euros avec 1,3 millions de mesures
nouvelles donc pour les yeux à peine ces
unités tout à fait dédiées à la prise en
charge des enfants victimes à la fois à
la détection l'accompagnement judiciaire
et bien sûr la prise en charge la
formation des professionnels reste
évidemment un axe important qui est
compris dans les budgets qui vous est
proposé la plateforme téléphonique
madame la ministre s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît
de conclure donc vous décidez à ma place
alors je vais vous demander quelque
chose madame la ministre on est toujours
on est toujours sur l'amendement 534
parce que vous avez vous n'avez donné
aucun numéro d'amendement madame la je
regroupe je regroupe 534 530 c'est pas
évident de faire ça comme ça 534 535 538
et 539 qui sont sur il y a des
amendements sur le financement
bon en tout cas si je résume je suis
défavorable à l'ensemble des des
amendements et je vous fais des réponses
groupées pour aller le plus vite
possible
j'essaie d'avoir une réponse concrète
excusez-moi mais bon en regroupant parce
que les sujets sont un peu mélangés sur
les corps recommandations de la civisme
je répète que nous mettons effectivement
dans ce budget 7,4 millions pour les
yeux à peine dont 1,3 millions de
mesures nouvelles sur la plateforme
téléphonique dédiée nous faisons nous
faisons 1,5 millions d'euros dédiés et
une campagne de communication sur les
jeunes majeurs comme je l'ai dit les 50
millions sont passés de la stratégie
pauvreté à la stratégie protection de
l'enfance évidemment nous serons
particulièrement vigilants et nous
travaillerons avec les départements dans
le cadre des CDPE sur les insertions des
jeunes dans les territoires ruraux comme
l'a dit mon collègue les dispositifs et
pris en charge notamment par le
ministère du Travail nous serons
particulièrement attentifs à la à la
façon dont le contrat d'engagement jeune
et l'accompagnement des jeunes majeurs
se fait dans les territoires ruraux le
mystère de l'éducation nationale et le
mystère de la de la de la
excuse-moi de l'enseignement supérieur
contribue aussi à l'accompagnement des
jeunes en ruralité sur la prostitution
un plan de 14 millions d'euros a été
déployés aujourd'hui nous allons 2,2
millions supplémentaires pour financer
amélioration des repérages dans les
maraude numérique et le développement de
structures spécialisées
voilà donc l'ensemble des amendements ne
me paraissent sans objet et je demande
le rejet
merci alors
la suite c'est l'amendement 548
c'est vous même la ministre
on peut pas savoir j'ai pas eu les
numéros
de la généralisation
sur la sur la généralisation des mesures
du Ségur donc ce sont les amendements
594 et 710 voilà permettre la
revalorisation de l'ensemble des métiers
financés par le programme 137 pour
permettre la généralisation de la prime
du Ségur aux salariés du programme 137
et bien en fait c'est justement ce qu'a
prévu l'amendement du Gouvernement que
vous avez adopté et qui vise à permettre
la compensation du Ségur ou structure de
la branche sanitaire et sociale non
médico-social dont font justement partie
les structures
œuvrant dans le champ de l'égalité femme
homme je vous propose donc de retirer
cet amendement
de l'amande des amandes s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît
allez
[Musique]
543 et 714
relative au parcours sortis de la
prostitution et à la fille aide
financière à l'insertion sociale donc
juste pour vous indiquer que
c'est toute cette politique et financée
par le programme 137 à hauteur de 2,5
millions d'euros pour les têtes de
réseau et la fiche plus 2,1 million
d'euros au niveau local pour accompagner
pour accompagner accompagner les
personnes en situation de prostitution
en 2022 au titre des mesures nouvelles
se sont ajoutées 1,2 millions d'euros
pour financer les parcours de sortie et
la fiche et je précise que s'agissant
justement du montant de la fils il a été
revalorisé de 4% à compter de juillet
2022 et que mesure est intégrée dans le
PLF 2023 dans le cas d'une mesure
nouvelle à hauteur de 200000 euros donc
je propose soit le retrait de cet
amendement ou à défaut je serai
défavorable et
s'agissant
des observatoire des féminicides c'est
le l'amendement 542
donc défavorable contenu du fait que il
y a une étude sur les morts violentes
publiées chaque année par le ministère
de l'intérieur des retours d'expérience
ordonnées maintenant depuis
les suites du Grenelle donc ordonnée par
le ministre de la Justice donc qui
demande au parquet de faire de remonter
des retours d'expérience après chaque
féminicide et puis je précise aussi que
nous avons des observatoires
territoriaux qui sont mis en place donc
dans différents territoires et que
j'attacherai d'ailleurs une importance
particulière au développement de ces
observatoires territoriaux qui
permettent de voir au mieux justement la
réalité des violences faites aux femmes
et en particulier des féminicides donc
je serai aussi défavorable comme je l'ai
indiqué à cet amendement voilà madame la
Présidente merci
madame la ministre je pense que vous
faites tous les autres bien je vais je
vais aller rapidement
dis donc il s'agit donc des amendements
509 et 541 qui concerne les esats et le
fond de transformation des esates alors
vous le savez tout et tout ce fonds de
transformation a été mis en œuvre
l'an dernier en 2000 enfin cette année
en 2022 et d'écouler des crédits de
plantes du plan de relance à l'heure
actuelle ces crédits sont en cours même
pas d'attribution on les projets sont en
cours de repérage et d'arbitrage au
niveau des ARS qui feront des
contractualisations
avec les projets retenus de façon
progressive entre cette fin d'année et
le premier semestre de l'année 2023 donc
ces fonds ne sont pas utilisés
aujourd'hui les fonds de 2022 donc ils
sont à disposition pour l'année 2023 ce
que nous vous proposons c'est d'éval ce
que ces fonds auront la façon dont ils
auront été consommés et de prévoir pour
2024 une avancée sur ces fonds de
transformation des esats parce que ces
fonds sont importants néanmoins puisque
ils vont participer à la transformation
de ces établissements et surtout aux
investissements dans l'outil de
production qui permettra
d'évoluer dans les modes de formation et
de d'emploi des personnes en situation
de handicap donc je vous propose ou de
retirer ces amendements ou
je me je navigue défavorable
d'accord
bon donc moi j'ai un peu de trou mais
bon peut-être que c'est bien
de toute façon vous êtes défavorable à
tous voilà donc on va mettre au bois à
madame la ministre vous avez demandé non
donc je vais mettre au voie donc ses
amendements
pour le gouvernement donc tous les avis
sont défavorables à moins que vous
retiriez
un amendement donc je commence par le
422 donc avis de la commission
défavorable gouvernement aussi qui est
pour
qui est contre
le 423 même avis même vote
le 534 même ma vie
même ma vie même vote
ok 424 même avis même vote
533 ma vie même vote le 535 même avis
même vote 538 plein ma vie même vote le
539 même avis même vote
alors s'ils ne sont pas d'accord on me
le dit et je fais le vote donc le 539
qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient et donc
pas adopté
amendement alors la Commission à chaque
avis du gouvernement je suppose que vous
suivez la vie qui a été donnée s'il y a
si ça n'est pas ça vous me le direz donc
les amendements identiques 385 416 658
donc avec des favorable de la commission
du gouvernement monsieur mouillé
madame la Présidente moi j'interviens
arrêtez pour l'ensemble de ces
amendements qui concerne le même sujet
qui soit des crocodistes supplémentaires
moi ce que je vous propose j'ai entendu
il avait de la commission j'ai besoin de
bien entendu la vie du gouvernement mais
ça vous auriez pu devenir 15 minutes on
a eu une vision globale de la ville
nigative du gouvernement sur l'ensemble
mais pour revenir sur ses amendements ce
que je vous propose c'est peut-être de
soutenir mon amendement l'amendement de
60 qui a le même objet et qui apporte
des crédits on va dire plus raisonnables
à la contribution donc ça donne le
message des moyens supplémentaires pour
l'accompagnement des jeunes majeurs sont
pour s'aggraver de façon trop importante
les autres lignes budgétaires donc si
vous en êtes d'accord mes chers
collègues ce serait voilà c'est une
profession que je vous fais c'est de
maintenir de soutenir donc cet
amendement regardez des des enjeux des
précédents
donc monsieur Savary
tous monsieur le ministre madame la
ministre on connaît tous des difficultés
justement moi aussi dans le département
de la Marne j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer l'UDAF et des difficultés
donc avec la protection des des majeurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle il nous
paraît important et visiblement pour un
nombre de sénateurs surtout c'est bon de
faire en sorte de donner des des moyens
supplémentaires c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je soutiendrai ces amants
alors j'ai connu signé l'amendement de
Monsieur Lefebvre avec d'autres et je
crois que pour
tenir compte effectivement des soucis
budgétaires il serait peut-être
intéressant de se rallier me semble-t-il
si
docteur Chassin est d'accord également
de se rallier à la proposition de de
Philippe mouiller ça donnera quand même
un signe
positif dans cette demande là tout en
respectant les purs budgétaires ça varie
vous retirer l'amendement donc de
Monsieur Lefebvre
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues donc moi effectivement
dans mon département j'ai beaucoup de
problèmes effectivement avec la
protection des jeunes majeurs mais
je comprends que il faut aussi faire des
efforts et je veux bien me rallier à
l'amendement de Philippe mouiller
merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames monsieur
le ministre il me semble sous votre
contrôle vous avoir entendu dire que
dans ce dans le cas de ce budget il y
avait une progression de 12 millions
d'euros sur cet item protection des
majeurs
7,1 et la demande est de 40 millions
dans l'amendement j'avais demandé l'avis
du gouvernement pour avoir une idée de
du delta
l'avis de la commission des finances
évidemment et
empreinte sagesse budgétaire donc dans
la mesure où il y a 7 millions déjà de
progression et des difficultés de
recrutement des difficultés aussi pour
former les personnels on en restera donc
un avis défavorable mais avec une
vigilance particulière l'année prochaine
puisque manifestement nous dit qu'il y a
des problèmes sur le terrain un peu
partout donc avis défavorable merci
Monsieur Roux est-ce que vous retirez
l'amendement ou monsieur bilak
au profit oui et retirez merci Madame le
wérou je mets au vote votre amendement
ou vous le retirez
non non donc il est avant il est avant
vous le maintenez d'accord donc je mets
aux voix donc l'amendement 548 qui a eu
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient et donc
pas adopté je mets l'amendement 60 de
Monsieur mouillé qui a reçu donc un avis
défavorable du gouverne de la Commission
et du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
donc adopté
amendement 537 donc avec des favorables
de la Commission et du gouvernement qui
est pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
pas adopter amendement identique 549 594
même avis même vote
l'amendement 710 même
bon oui bon si vous voulez même la
présidente billon donc nous mettons
l'amendement 594 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient donc pas
adopter l'amendement donc 710
favorable la Commission du gouvernement
qui est pour contre s'abstient ils n'ont
pas adopter les amendements 509 et
541 quand même à ma vie même votre
merci
mon 503 même avis même vote
amendement 554 avis favorable de la
commission avis défavorable du
gouvernement même Lubin oui merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre bonne
je vous avais déjà questionné sur ce
sujet lorsque vous avez été lorsque vous
êtes venus devant la commission des
affaires sociales m'avait répondu à
l'époque que il existait monsieur il
existait une sinistre combe pardon il
existait une une
ligne de 10 millions d'euros dans le
PLFSS je suis allé voir mais cette ligne
elle est elle est certes à la main des
ARS mais elle est entièrement consommée
et on ne peut absolument pas aujourd'hui
penser qu'une ARS pourra dégager un
million d'euros pour un
projet dans un département donc même si
vous m'avez parlé d'une d'une enquête de
Liga en fin d'une étude de Liga ce je
trouve un petit peu dommage que vous ne
puissiez pas dégager 10 millions ou 12
millions sur ce budget ce qui quand même
n'est pas extraordinaire je je ne
comprends pas pour pouvoir
commencer à régler ce problème qui
pourtant vous tient à cœur
merci Monsieur mouillé
également cette amendement parce que
au-delà de l'état du lieu où vous avez
fait monsieur le ministre d'abord un
concrètement aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
moyen dédié au développement de ce type
d'opération des maisons de répit
d'ailleurs pour voir consulter la CNSA
ils sont également favorables enfin pas
favorable à l'amendement mais en tous
les cas ont besoin d'un fichage
complémentaire sur ce type de
financement auteur de 10000 euros et
concernant la mission mis en place par
les gaz le débat c'est le délai
puisqu'on est en phase de renvoyer à une
réflexion plus globale sur la branche
donc voilà donc dans l'attente je pense
qu'il serait extrêmement intéressant de
soutenir cette initiative les projets
sont prêts sur les territoires le
premier d'ailleurs d'Emma devrait
démarrer dans les Landes on a
aujourd'hui des phases opérationnelles
les ARS y sont plutôt favorables que
ceux problématique aujourd'hui c'est les
premiers crédits envoyés voilà un petit
fichier de 10 millions parce qu'il y a
10 projets je pense réellement
aujourd'hui c'est un besoin extrêmement
important et qu'il faut être acteur de
ce développement merci monsieur le
ministre
juste vous préciser que ça fait bien
partie des mesures nouvelles de l'OGD
dans le PLFSS paph il y a bien 10
millions d'euros pour les aidants dans
le PLFSS et d'ailleurs c'est des crédits
CNSA donc ça doit être dans le PDFs
merci alors je mets au voile amendement
554 qui a reçu un avis favorable de la
commission défavorable du gouvernement
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il est donc adopté là
maintenant 599
oui madame la Présidente merci de
redonner la parole moi je voudrais juste
rappeler que j'ai entendu le rapporteur
qui nous disait qu'il voyait plutôt ça
dans le budget de la justice je voudrais
juste rappeler que j'ai parlé de cette à
10000 jeunes mineurs qui se prostituent
l'année dernière il y avait des budgets
parce qu'il s'était un reliquat
lorsqu'on fait des politiques publiques
on s'engage pas pour une année on
s'engage dans la continuité alors cette
année il y a pas de budget fléchés pour
la prostitution des mineurs alors ça
sert à rien de demander des études ou
des missions à la procureur Renault qui
a fait un travail formidable avec des
propositions si on donne pas les moyens
derrière d'appliquer ce programme et ses
propositions qu'elle apportait nous
l'avions auditionné avec la délégation
au droit des femmes 7 à 10 mineurs je le
répète donc nous vous avons besoin
d'argent pour aider ces jeunes mineurs
donc je vous demande chers collègues de
côté cet amendement parce que si on
renvoie la balle à la justice le budget
de la justice il est passé donc c'est
terminé on ne protégera pas les mineurs
qui se prostituent en 2023
moi j'espère surtout que tous ceux qui
sont présents qui demandent la parole là
aujourd'hui seront là samedi également
merci beaucoup donc je mets au revoir
l'amendement 599 à madame la ministre
comme il le rapporteur l'a dit le plan
de lutte contre la prostitution a été
sorti très tard dans l'année 2022 les
appels à projet viennent juste d'être
attribués et donc on commence à dépenser
l'argent qui a été attribué en 2022 on
montera donc les actions auront lieu
donc en 2023 il nous faut les évaluer
pour les reconduire en 2024 donc on sera
sur la lutte contre la prostitution
croyez-moi tout à fait
à 19h20 j'arrête voilà tout le monde est
bien bien compris
amendement oui on a un président
pardonnez-moi mais là depuis tout à
l'heure on ne peut pas écouter les avis
à la fois des rapporteurs des ministres
de certains collègues qui ont déposé qui
ont pris du temps à déposer des
amendements je sais qu'on est dans un
temps contraint mais on est aussi là
pour débattre et pour faire correctement
la loi et pardonnez-moi mais quand on
défend un amendement quand on descend un
amendement on aime avoir la vie c'est
tout asseyez-vous monsieur j'ai juste je
vais vous répondre je vais vous répondre
la règle le règlement intérieur est
prévu ça c'est la c'est la règle
maintenant moi il y a pas de souci moi
c'est simplement qu'il va pas falloir
venir me dire que j'aurais dû accélérer
pour que justement cette mission ne soit
pas examinée en partie samedi il y a
l'ensemble des ministres il y a
l'ensemble des collègues monsieur
yakovelli je faisais pas donner la
parole c'est bon
alors maintenant je mets au foie
l'amendement 599 carrosses en avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre
il est adopté
amendement 554 avec des favorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté amendement 711 même avis même
vote mais la vie même votre 712 même
avis même vote
amendement 329 à commission
[Musique]
et le gouvernement
je sais pas qui a donné des favorable
également donc qui est pour
qui est contre qui ça tient il est
adopté amendement 543 qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté et
fait tomber le suivant le 714
668 avis défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté amendement 542 même avis même
vote
amendement 500 même à vie même vote
amendement 573 même ma vie même vote
amendement 574 même avis même vote
amendement 667 même avis même vote merci
nous passons à l'amendement 575 madame
ponce
merci madame la Présidente alors
largement des professionnels de la
filière socio-éducative telle que les
personnels logistiques techniques
administratif restent encore écartés de
la revalorisation salariale de 183 € net
contenu dans le Ségur de la santé par
exemple si la médiation familiale
s'inscrit tant au niveau politique que
budgétaire sur la ligne de soutien à la
parentalité les médiateurs et
médiatrices familiaux sont exclus des
accords du Ségur aussi les
professionnels des SADs des siads des
passades de la convention ban ne pouvant
cumuler le bénéfice du Ségur et de
l'avenant 43 qui était je le rappelle un
accord de branche antérieure à la crise
sanitaire se trouve à nouveau défavorisé
par rapport aux autres établissements
sanitaires et sociaux médico-sociaux
notamment les EHPAD et voit la crise
d'attractivité perdurer et s'aggraver le
Ségur répondait de la vue même du
Premier ministre à une urgence j'aime
bien justice nous proposons donc de
corriger une fois pour toute cette
injustice et d'allouer la prime de 183
euros ou aux oubliés du Ségur à savoir
toute personne travaillant dans un
établissement de la filière
socio-éducative aux médiateur et
médiatrices familiaux ainsi que les
services d'aide et d'accompagnement à
domicile et les centres de soins
infirmiers de la branche d'aide à
domicile deux ans après il est quand
même grand temps de mettre fin aux
oubliés du Ségur et au distorsions entre
secteurs comme en infra secteur et
établissement par cet établissement
d'appel nous proposons donc la création
d'un nouveau programme élargissement du
Ségur social à tous les personnels des
établissements que j'ai cité
précédemment je vous remercie merci la
vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
présidente le présente amendement
propose une ouverture de crédit auteur
de 500 millions d'euros pour financer la
revalorisation salariale des services
d'accompagnement et d'aide à domicile
l'extension de la mesure socle du Ségur
aux travailleurs sociaux se lève dans ce
PLF après de 50 millions d'euros en
outre 20 millions d'euros sont prévus
pour la revalorisation des travailleurs
dans les services de protection
maternelle et infantile il s'agit à
notre sens d'un amendement d'appel
destiné au gouvernement c'est donc une
demande de retrait pour nous
merci du gouvernement
575 qui a reçu un avis défavorable
d'accord
qui est contre qui s'abstient n'est donc
pas adopté trois amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune deux
amendements
identiques
monsieur le Président Roquier
merci madame la Présidente
sa collègue la décongélation de la
location du handicapé et il avancée très
importante pour les personnes
handicapées elle va enfin mettre un
terme au lieu de dépendance financière
entre le bénéficiaire de la hache et son
conjoint et ainsi assurés plus
d'autonomie aux personnes concernées
cette réforme
au 1er octobre 2023 le temps que les
différents outils soient mis en place
toutefois lors des débats du projet de
loi pour voir l'achat lui des
solidarités d'autonomies et des
personnes handicapées j'ai dit
favorables à une entrée en Bigard plus
rapide si cela s'avérait possible
techniquement
qui est porté par Maurice Carrère visant
croyez davantage de crédit au programme
157 handicaps et dépendances pour
permettre le financement de la
déconjugarisation avant octobre 2023
afin que les musiciens de la hache
puisse bénéficier au plus vite de cette
réforme
merci la maman 555 mammoniers je vais
écourter mon collègue lundi c'est à la
fois pour permettre le financement de
cette décongélisation avant octobre et
de 23 et interroger le gouvernement sur
une potentielle rétroactivité de la
mesure à compter du premier avril 23
rappelons que la bande-annonce
financière vis-à-vis de son partenaire
qui est en train de se moque de calcul
actuel pénalise toute particulièrement
les femmes en situation
d'être victime de violence conjugales on
estime que 34% dentelle d'entraîne
subissent des violences commises par
leur partenaires contre 19% des femmes
non handicapées merci le 540 madame le
haut Hérault
alors il s'agit d'un amendement qui vise
à étendre au-delà de 60 ans le droit de
toucher la hache pour les personnes qui
en sont titulaires avec un taux
d'incapacité permanente située entre 50
et 79%. il y a un trou de couverture
entre la fin de la à 60 ans et le
potentiel bénéfice de l'ASPA donc
l'allocation de solidarité aux personnes
âgées qui elles ne peut débarrer que à
partir de 62 ans donc il y a vraiment un
trou de couverture qu'il s'agit ici de
combler
merci la vie de la commission je le
rapporteur
478 et 555 qui sont identiques un moment
qui demande à anticiper la mise en place
de la déconjugualisation de la hache au
1er avril 2023 nous avons interrogé lors
de nos auditions l'administration la
DGCS sur le sujet il nous a été
effectivement dit que ce heurter les
obstacles techniques importants il nous
a été indiqué que l'ensemble des
systèmes d'information relatifs aux
prestations sociales étaient à ce jour
fondé sur une logique familiarisée et
que la mesure impliquée à cet égard
d'important travaux d'adaptation nous
sommes restés un peu perplexe je
voudrais que le gouvernement nous
confirme qu'il se dit effectivement de
problèmes techniques de mise en oeuvre
de cette décongélisation au 1er avril
sur le 540 l'amendement visant étendre
au-delà des 60 ans le droit de toucher
l'âge 2 pour mémoire la H2 et verser aux
personnes dans le taux d'incapacité est
compris entre 50 et 79% contre 80% au
moins pour la H1 et subissant des
restrictions substantielles et durables
d'accès à l'emploi
il s'agit donc d'une prestation destinée
par nature aux actifs passer là de 60
ans les personnes concernées relèvent
donc de l'assurance vieilles ou de
l'ASPA en tout état de cause la règle
selon laquelle le bénéfice l'âge de
prend fin à l'âge auquel le bénéficiaire
est réputé inapte au travail et prévu
par l'article
l821-2 du code de la sécurité sociale
c'est amendement de crédit doit être
donc être considéré comme un amendement
d'appel on peut tout de même interroger
le gouvernement sur la fixation de ces
tâches à 60 ans soit avant l'âge de la
retraite donc pour ces trois amendements
c'est une demande de retrait mais avec
demande de précision du gouvernement sur
l'aspect technique merci David du
gouvernement madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente oui la hache
la déconjugalisation la mise en oeuvre
de la déconjugalisation et beaucoup plus
technique on ne peut l'imaginer
notamment pour la Caisse nationale
d'allocation familiale qui traite le
système informatique qui construit le
système
informatique
qui va permettre de pouvoir mettre en
place pour les bénéficiaires cet âge
donc nous sommes engagés à
mettre en place des décrets qui sont en
cours d'examen actuellement au niveau de
la
CNCPH qui seront signés vers mi-décembre
et ensuite la Caisse nationale
d'allocations familiales travaille sur
ce système d'information qui est
complexe qui est très complexe parce que
cette caisse n'a pas l'habitude de
travailler
avec des revenus déconjugués au
contraire tout les cautions familiaux
sont sont font partie de de du système
de construction du système d'information
de la caisse donc c'est pour le 1er
octobre et ce à quoi je me suis engagé
c'est que si les choses étaient prêtes
techniquement avant ce serait mis en
oeuvre dès qu'elle serait prête
techniquement l'important est que les
préparations soient fines afin qu'il n'y
ait pas de bug à la mise en oeuvre de de
la hache des conjugués pour les usagers
pour la hache
un et deux vous l'avez dit là jusqu'à
l'âge de 62 ans permet d'assurer sans
continuité avec l'âge d'ouverture des
droits une pension de retraite et à la
SPA il ne paraît pas souhaitable en
revanche d'aller au-delà et permettre
aux bénéficiaires de la hache de
percevoir celles-ci sans limitations de
durée comme c'est le cas pour les
bénéficiaires de la hache 1
pour bénéficier de la he2 la personne
doit avoir donc un taux d'incapacité
compris entre 50% et
79%, mais celui-ci doit être assorti
d'une restriction substantielle et
durable pour l'accès à l'emploi elle ne
peut être attribuée pour une durée
supérieure à cinq ans contrairement à la
hache 1 qui peut être attribué sans
limitation de durée donc la possibilité
pour les bénéficiaires de la hache 1 de
conserver la prestation au-delà de l'âge
de la retraite se justifie au regard de
la possibilité de se voir reconnaître un
droit sans limitation de durée et les
bénéficiaires de l'âge de ont la
possibilité de faire une demande d'Aspa
dont le montant est comparable à celui
de l'âge près de m'excuser pour cette
réponse technique mais je vous propose
donc c'est un avis défavorable du
gouvernement sur ces deux amendements
sur ces trois amendements où on avis de
retrait comme la demande des monsieur le
rapporteur merci beaucoup alors je mets
aux voix la main les amendements 478 et
155 qui ont reçu des avis 555 pardon qui
ont reçu donc des avis défavorables de
la Commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient pas à
même de Seine
merci madame la Présidente c'est
amendement vise à mettre fin à une
injustice dans la fonction publique
hospitalière pour quelques
professionnels travaillant dans des
établissements médico-sociaux en
particulier dans les secteurs du
handicap et de la protection de
l'enfance ce sont les oubliés du Ségur
c'est 03% des personnels de la Fonction
publique hospitalière qui ne bénéficient
pas du complément de traitement
indiciaire soit 183 euros mensuels les
établissements médico-sociaux ne peuvent
pas lutter contre le départ de leur
salarié vers des établissements ou des
postes équivalents sont valorisés par un
gain de pouvoir d'achat ces fortes
disparité entre les personnels
fragilisées désorganisent ces
établissements qui peinent à conserver
leur personnel et à recruter c'est
amendement propose donc un élargissement
des bénéficiaires du complètement de
traitement indiciaire merci la vie de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente la pertinence
de cet amendement sur les crédits de la
mission solidarité peut être interrogée
car il semble davantage relevés de la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale en tout état de cause c'est à
l'évidence un amendement d'appel parce
que le montant demandé soit 15 millions
d'euros ne nous semble pas correspondre
réellement au coût du dispositif
envisagé c'est donc une demande de
retrait merci
mais ma vie du gouvernement
et je vais retirer cet amendement mais
comprenez bien que sur le terrain il y a
une incompréhension de l'exclusion de
certains personnels que ça désorganise
vraiment les établissements et que
finalement c'est la situation de ces
jeunes qui ont besoin d'un
accompagnement et d'une protection qui
est mise en cause pardon merci la maman
545 madame le wérou
donc c'est un amendement qui vise à
octroyer 2 millions d'euros
supplémentaires à la plateforme
téléphonique 39 19 donc la plateforme
d'écoute et d'information et
d'orientation à destination des femmes
victimes de violence il faut saluer tout
d'abord les efforts pour améliorer
l'accueil téléphonique de ces usagers en
détresse notamment l'évolution du
fonctionnement de la plateforme en juin
2021 vers le 24 heures sur 24 pour
autant selon le dernier bleu budgétaire
cette plateforme a un taux d'appel
traité en 2021 de 62% ce qui laisse 38%
des usagers sans réponse le gouvernement
s'était fixé pour objectif dans le
budget 2022 à 85% de réponses en 2023
l'objectif est à la baisse à 75% donc
c'est assez incompréhensible cette
hausse donc du budget que nous demandons
est nécessaire au regard de la pauvreté
des moyens octroyés au 39 19 et nous
proposons donc voilà d'augmenter ce
budget parce que le coût de ces
non-répons et de la non prise en charge
de ces personnes les coûts indirects
sont plus importants une étude de
plusieurs structures de recherche dont
le centre d'étude européenne de Sciences
Po montre que le coût
je dirais des violences sexuelles et
sexistes évalué à 3,6 milliards d'euros
donc ce coût pour la société est
largement supérieure au 2 millions
d'euros supplémentaires qu'il vous est
proposé d'allouer à cette plateforme
merci merci
non la vie de la commission
d'abord la vie de la commission sur le
rapporteur merci modèle le président
pardon madame la ministre ce sera très
rapide très rapide
il nous paraît évident qu'il est
nécessaire d'accompagner la montée en
puissance du dispositif passé de 24
heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 depuis
2021 néanmoins le PLF prévoit déjà dans
sa version initiale une dotation dédiée
de 2,9 millions d'euros qui a été doublé
en première lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale l'amendement paraît donc
satisfait ça sera donc de la part de la
commission des finances une demande de
retraite merci Madame la Ministre la vie
du gouvernement
pardon madame la Présidente comme l'a
dit la commission
je suggère le retrait de cet abonnement
puisque le PLF adopté en première
lecture l'Assemblée nationale a attribué
2,9 millions d'euros pour accompagner
justement la structuration du 39 19 par
la FNSF je précise d'ailleurs que le 2
fois plus d'appels sont prises en charge
depuis 2017 on est à peu près 90 000
appels et plus 114% d'augmentation du
budget du 39 19 depuis 2017 donc je
propose de retirer cet amendement ou à
défaut je suis défavorable merci retirez
donc je mets aux voix donc cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable comme mission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est donc pas adopté
maintenant 669 même pour c'est mon
Président c'est amendement propose
d'injecter 2 millions d'euros
supplémentaires à l'action dédiée à
l'égalité professionnelle afin tout
d'abord de mesurer les inégalités entre
secteur professionnel puis l'impact
correct des actions de revalorisation
alors juste valeur des métiers des
secteurs après dominance féminine
l'index de l'égalité professionnelle a
permis depuis 2018 la publication
annuelle des résultats des entreprises
en matière d'égalité femme homme sur les
salaires en 2022 la note moyenne qu'il
attribue de 86 sur 100 8 entreprises sur
10 seraient donc parfaitement égalitaire
et pourtant comme chaque année ce 4
novembre les femmes en France ont
commencé à travailler gratuitement selon
le calcul des glorieux du fait des
inégalités persistantes de salaires
entre femmes et hommes alors quel est le
problème les critères de l'index de
l'égalité
ignorent un élément majeur les
inégalités entre secteurs professionnels
certains secteurs majoritairement
féminins sont mal voire très mal
rémunéré comme les secteurs du prendre
soin des aides soignants les infirmières
les aides à domicile les caissières et
les caissières aussi ces métiers dont on
a reconnu le caractère essentiel pendant
la crise du covid alors que faire le
Québec en 1995 a décidé d'appliquer le
principe de l'équité salariale tous les
salariés ont reçu un questionnaire pour
évaluer les spécificités de leur emploi
et une étude a été conduite dans tout le
pays pour prendre en compte ces données
dans les salaires moyens et rééquilibrer
les salaires par secteur un milliard de
dollars a été injecté pour impulser la
revalorisation prioritairement des
secteurs mal rémunérés
enfin des secteurs professionnels
majoritairement d'ailleurs féminin bien
entendu nous gagnerons donc plusieurs
décennies dans la lutte pour l'égalité à
faire de même et c'est pour cela que le
groupe vous propose cet amendement merci
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
oui c'est un rendement viseur renforcer
de 2 millions d'euros les moyens
déployés au titre de l'index de
l'égalité professionnelle ce dispositif
relève cependant du programme 111
amélioration de la qualité de l'emploi
et des relations du travail de la
mission de travail et emploi et en
pratique de la direction générale du
travail il ne semble donc que ça ne
relève pas de cette mission et donc ce
n'est pas le support approprié demande
de retrait merci la vie du gouvernement
madame la ministre
oui je m'associe à la vie de la
commission
s'agissant de cette demande de retrait
ou sinon j'ai bien envie défavorable
précisant également que c'est une somme
totale de 143 millions d'euros qui est
affecté à l'égalité professionnelle
à travers la politique transversale la
terre à travers le document de politique
transversal menée donc sur ce sujet
alors je mets aux voix donc cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable la Commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient donc pas
adopter un moment 597 la présidente
billon merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues les Centres
d'Information sur les Droits des femmes
et des familles appelées CIDFF sont des
organismes de droit privé constitués
sous forme d'association ils font
l'objet d'un agrément par l'État afin de
mettre à disposition des femmes et des
familles toutes les informations utiles
tentant à promouvoir les droits des
femmes je connais leur difficulté je
connais leur engagement pour toujours
mieux accompagner ses victimes alors je
me félicite évidemment des 1,6 millions
d'euros qui sont prévus au projet de loi
de finances pour renforcer les CIDFF et
leur cœur de métier cependant ces
crédits ne prennent pas en compte la
nécessaire revalorisation des salaires
du personnel des CIDFF qui n'a pas
bénéficié de revalor des revalorisation
récentes donc c'est l'objet de cet
amendement revaloriser la subvention
allouée au CIDFF afin de garantir à
juste niveau de rémunération des
personnels de ces associations je vous
remercie merci la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
et les auteurs de l'amendement un effort
budgétaire a déjà été accompli par le
PLF avec un relèvement de moyens de 1,6
millions d'euros pour le financement de
l'État qui est au total à 6,3 millions
d'euros je voudrais qu'il y a des
financements locaux aussi
complémentaires très important c'est
donc une demande de retrait merci la vie
de du gouvernement madame la ministre
oui je rappelle effectivement cette
cette somme de 1,6 millions d'euros donc
ajouter au PLF 2023 pour les CDF et je
précise également que les salariés du
CIDF pourront aussi bénéficier de la
revalisation de la revalorisation des
salaires au titre justement de la prime
Ségur puisqu'elle font partie
elles et ils font partie justement de ce
champ visé par par la généralisation de
cette prime donc je propose que cet
amendement soit retiré ou à défaut j'ai
bien David défavorable merci donc je me
vois là maintenant 597 car aussi un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre
n'est pas adopté
alors deux amendements
identiques le 690 madame Schillinger oui
merci la maman défendue touche à un
sujet qui me tient à cœur celui de la
lutte contre la précarité menstruelle en
octobre 2019 je rendais en effet un
rapport intitulé précarité menstruelle
changeons les règles ce rapport mettait
en lumière la détresse dans laquelle se
trouvait et se trouve encore aujourd'hui
près de 2 millions de femmes en France
au moment de leurs règles pour ces
femmes souvent en situation de précarité
avoir accès à des protections
périodiques revient souvent à devoir
choisir entre des besoins entre aussi
essentiels que l'hygiène ou
l'alimentation je parle de choix même
s'il ne peut choisir que l'un d'un choix
contraint car l'on ne décide pas d'avoir
ou non ces règles avec ce rapport il
s'agissait donc de lever le voile sur le
tabou que représente les règles et
d'insister sur la nécessité d'y
consacrer un véritable une véritable
politique publique les règles s'avèrent
encore pour trop de femmes des facteurs
d'exclusion et d'aggravation des
discriminations qu'elles peuvent
connaître dans le prolongement de ce
rapport j'avais appuyé avec mes
collègues RDPI l'expérimentation de la
mise à disposition gratuite des
protections en direction des publics les
plus fragiles ce sont ainsi un million
d'euros qui qui avait été consacré et
fort porté en suite à 5 millions d'euros
en 2021 et reconduit pour le même
montant dans le cadre du projet de loi
de finance 2023 si je salue la prise de
conscience du Gouvernement sur ce sujet
et l'engagement du président de la
République en la matière il faut
reconnaître qu'il reste encore beaucoup
de chemin à parcourir aussi l'amendement
défendu propose d'accroître de 20% les
moyens financiers consacrés à ce sujet
il s'agit d'un effort non négligeable
mais qui reste raisonnable et qui est
sur tous légitime au moment où l'accès à
des protections périodiques et rendus
encore plus difficile du fait de la
hausse généralisée des prix je conclurai
en remerciant notamment les sénateurs de
mon groupe mais aussi ceux du écologiste
qui s'engage et soutiennent avec moi ce
combat et j'espère que le gouvernement
qui n'est pas en reste de ce sujet sans
être attentif à cette proposition
le 697 même pensé mon gilet défendu
si vous me permettez je vais quand même
prendre la parole ça nous répéterai pas
été dit voilà
ce il faut comprendre quand même que cet
amendement est complémentaire des
mesures dont on vient de parler de cette
fameuse ligne 5 millions d'euros et qui
a été reconduite et dont ce dont se
félicite mais c'est ça il s'agit un
petit peu de mesure complémentaires afin
d'accroître les actions de
sensibilisation sur les menstruations et
le bon usage des protections périodiques
en milieu scolaire et auprès des femmes
précaires et aussi de permettre la
formation d'intervenants sociaux sur ces
sujets donc c'est un petit peu une
mesure d'accompagnement pour rendre tout
à fait efficient les les la ligne de 5
millions d'euros qui a été reconduite
voilà merci la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
la Présidente c'est un sujet dont nous
avons débattu à plusieurs reprises ici
même donc il est proposé d'ajouter un
million un budget de 5 millions d'euros
je note toutefois qu'un effort
budgétaire a déjà été mené dans dans un
sens favorable puisque ces produits sont
maintenant soumis un taux de TVA de
réduit de 5,5 %. je crois qu'il sera
d'ailleurs intéressant de regarder
l'évolution des prix ces dernières
années pour voir si ce genre de mesure
est efficace ou pas parce que un sujet
qu'on a régulièrement en commission des
finances et ici même en séance publique
mais au-delà de cette remarque nous
avons rendu un avis de sagesse merci la
vie du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vous confirme que c'est un sujet
extrêmement important parce qu'il touche
à la dignité des personnes que nous
accompagnons c'est un sujet l'hygiène
l'accès l'hygiène et en particulier
l'hygiène menstruelle un sujet qui est
essentiel pour l'inclusion des personnes
qui sont en situation de précarité et en
particulier des femmes vous l'avez dit
on a fait un effort important en recond
le budget de 5 millions d'euros vous
dire aussi que il y a d'autres crédits
qui sont consacrés à l'accès à l'hygiène
dans le soutien qu'on apporte aux
associations de lutte contre les
exclusions et ce sujet fera l'objet à la
fois d'une évaluation d'une réévaluation
dans le cadre de la mise en place du
Pacte des solidarités à partir de 2024
donc si vous voulez bien je vous propose
de retirer votre abonnement pour qu'on
continue sur cette lignée en 2023 et on
continuera à investir sur cette question
pour les années suivantes
merci donc je mets au voile et les
amendements
identiques 190 1897 Congo c'est un avis
de sagesse de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui ça tient ils sont
donc adoptés amendement 624 la
présidente
merci madame la Présidente avec cet
amendement je vous propose de rehausser
les crédits à louer au financement des
centres de prise en charge des auteurs
de violence élément essentiel dans
l'arsenal de lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes ces centres ont été
développés après le Grenelle des
violences conjugales et on en décompte
une trentaine aujourd'hui sur tout le
territoire ces centres présentent de
nombreuses avantages que je vais pas
développer ce soir pour gagner du temps
donc la mise en place de ces centres
elle nécessite des moyens c'est l'objet
de cet amendement la prise en charge des
auteurs de violence doit faire partie de
l'arsenal encore plus de lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes je vous
remercie merci la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur merci madame la
Présidente les crédits consacrés à ces
centres lancé en 2021 explique déjà la
majeure partie de la hausse des dépenses
relatives de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes dans le
budget qui ne proposait cette année il
nous semble qu'il faut maintenant
laisser le temps au dispositif de monter
en puissance alors que les centres sont
à peine créés d'ailleurs les auditions
que nous avons conduites ne nous ont pas
permis d'identifier une problématique
particulière de sous-financement en la
matière en revanche madame la ministre
en revanche les associations avec qui
nous avons échangé considèrent que le
financement de ces centres devrait
relever du budget de la justice et non
du programme 137 dont l'objet devrait
être centré sur le soutien aux victimes
demande de retraite merci David du
gouvernement madame la ministre
oui effectivement madame la Présidente
pas de protection des victimes sans
prévention de la récidive nous sommes
bien d'accord les 30 centres de prise en
charge auront été ouverts accueilli plus
de 12000 personnes déjà
4,68 millions d'euros ont été mis donc
en 2022 + 2021 + 1,3 millions en 2022 et
je précise que le cahier des charges
prévoyait des co-financement et que
justement les CPCA sont en train de
développer leur partenariat donc il est
un peu tôt effectivement pour abonder
les budgets qui leur sont octroyés donc
je propose que cet amendement soit
retiré ou à défaut j'ai mis un avis
défavorable merci donc je mets aux
voiles à maintenant 624 qui a reçu donc
un avis défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
ça se tient il n'est pas adopté
maintenant 576 même pensé mon
président alors par cet amendement
d'appel nous demandons la mise en place
d'un revenu minimum garanti afin de
permettre à chacune et chacun de vivre
dignement le récent rapport du Secours
Catholique qui état de la pauvreté en
France 2022 souligne que deux ans après
le début de la crise
48% des ménages rencontrés par
l'association en 2021 se retrouve dans
l'incapacité de couvrir leurs dépenses
alimentaires quotidiennes ces dernières
années l'écart entre le taux de pauvreté
avant redistribution et le taux de
pauvreté après redistribution ne cesse
de grandir soulignant le rôle majeur des
prestations et aide face à
l'appauvrissement et la précarisation
d'une partie de la population toutefois
et bien que participant largement à la
réduction de 7 points et demi du taux de
pauvreté par les prestations sociales
les minima sociaux ne garantissent pas
un niveau de vie suffisant et descend la
stigmatisation des allocataires et les
montants de prestation trop faibles
maintiennent une partie de nos
concitoyens dans des situations de
détresse qui les éloignent de l'emploi
et du logement des sphères essentielles
à l'intégration sociale le revenu
minimum garanti consiste en un minimum
social pour chaque adulte sans emploi ou
ayant de faibles revenus sans
contrepartie et ceux des 18 ans son
montant à hauteur de 60% du revenu
médian permet de garantir à chaque
individu des conditions d'existence non
inférieures au seuil de pauvreté la mise
en place d'un revenu minimum garanti et
non seulement une réponse à l'urgence
sociale mais aussi une mesure de justice
il s'agit enfin de privilégier l'action
structurelle aux mesures ponctuelles
bon merci beaucoup alors juste je vais
me permettre en tant que présidente de
la séance de vous dire que nous allons
être dans je sais pas 3 minutes je pense
à 19h20 donc je veux bien prolonger de 5
minutes mais je peux pas aller au-delà
donc chacun effectivement peut défendre
son amendement en se moquant de ceux qui
sont derrière et qui devront revenir
samedi donc la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur merci la vie du
gouvernement même à vie je mets aux voix
donc l'amendement
576 qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ils n'ont
pas adopté l'amendement 670 même pensé
Monge non il n'est pas défendu je suis
désolé oh bah écoutez non mais c'est les
violences sur les femmes on va quand
même y consacrer 30 secondes
donc
bon bah du coup je vous me fait perdre
du temps c'est tout ce que vous faites
il s'agit donc bon ben je passe je passe
les raisons
bon il est défendu mais je trouve ça
quand même oui je tiens quand même à
utiliser les secondes pour dire que les
violences faites aux femmes on a
manifesté c'est toujours un problème en
France et donc il est temps de donner
les crédits à la hauteur de ce qu'on
demande à savoir
la Commission demande de retrait la vie
du gouvernement même avis mais ma vie je
mets aux voix donc l'amendement 70
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient donc pas adopter nous
allons procéder au vote des crédits de
la mission solidarité insertion égalité
des champs figurant à l'étape B je n'ai
été saisi d'aucune demande d'explication
de vote avant l'expiration du délai
limite je vous rappelle que la
commission des finances est favorable à
l'adoption des crédits de cette mission
je vais donc le mettre au bois qui est
pour
qui est contre s'abstient sont donc
adoptés l'article 46
quater et les amendements tendant
insérer des articles additionnels qui
sont attachés pour leur examen au crédit
de la mission solidarité insertion
égalité des changes je vais mettre
l'article 46water au vote qui est pour
contre qui s'abstient donc adopté
articles additionnels après l'article
46water deux amendements identiques sur
Mohamed soit ligne
brièvement que nous vous proposons visa
permettre la mise en oeuvre dans mon
département d'une avancée majeure que
nous avons voté ici il était dernier la
décojugalisation de la location adulte
handicapée je vous demande chers
collègues de voter cet amendement merci
la vie de la commission
imposable la vie du gouvernement qui est
identique
favorable oui
et votre amendement est défendu
l'amendement du Gouvernement
voilà merci donc je mets aux voix donc
ces deux amendements identiques donc
avis de du gouvernement favorable à vis
de la commission favorable qui est pour
contre qui s'abstient donc adopter
l'amendement 418 monsieur Corbis il est
défendu et pour remercier d'avoir mis
deux minutes supplémentaires je dois me
ramènerai un petit Maroilles la fin des
trois mois
je vous remercie beaucoup pour le
Maroilles vous savez que on en produit
aussi dans mon département
avis de la commission merci la vie du
gouvernement
à vie favorable pour la raison que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure avis favorable
merci donc je mets aux voix donc la
maman 418 avis défavorable de la
commission à vie favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient pas adopter
donc
nous allons passer à la mission suivante
voilà et le temps que je
que les ministres s'en aille chacun
s'installe faire une petite annonce donc
par courrier en date du 28 novembre
madame Éliane assassy présidente du
groupe CRCE demande l'inscription second
point de l'ordre du jour